Oh my god, I sound like a fucking dying whale right now
My sliding door, okay, I love how I'm like I'm getting better Let me like, huh, let me just put like eight streams for this week Like with three of those days being double streams
Say no
It was all a lie, it was all a fucking lie
Oh my god, or maybe I got sick and then it lowered my What was it called?
What's that word called?
It lowered my my defenses I'm more easily I'm more easily persuaded now to do things But Doki, you said no to day two, look guys if my team did not have Oh, yeah, my lowering my inhibitions and my team Didn't have a stronger peer pressure Pre-pressure towards me.
I would have said yes to day two.
I It was the environment I was in because my team Didn't want to do day two, but I was like, oh, that's not good Let's negotiate guys
Let's negotiate guys, come on
But my team was stronger, they were stronger Did Rae survive?
That is a very good question Rae, are you okay?
Let me write that in our group chat Rae are you okay?
My chat wants to know are you me and me too by the way and me as well My chat wants to know Rae are you okay?
And did you survive okay
Okay, I Just need to know I Need to know but yes, I'm unfortunately I couldn't make it today too.
I Oh, he's typing, he's alive!
Guys, he's fucking, he's typing!
Guys, he made it!
He's alive!
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
I still can't believe we actually made it Oh, yeah, it only hit me for a couple of hours I just slept through it and now the sun is out!
Bro, he literally slept through Milton.
Oh my god.
He doesn't give a fuck.
He was like if it hits, it hits.
At least I'm sleeping.
He slept through fucking Milton.
Oh my god, like I think how I don't understand.
Isn't it loud?
Wouldn't it be like loud if a hurricane's coming through?
I don't know.
I've lived through typhoons, but not hurricanes.
So I have no idea.
Anyway, as I was saying, I still can't believe we made it today too.
I really did have like, I'm sorry I like, I don't know why I was like, there's no way we'll make it today too Because in my I feel like in my head I was like, oh, there's a lot of actual good teams there I was like Like pretty casual about it I assume we were really casual about it because none of all of us don't play Deadlocked that much so I was very surprised We ended up making it.
I feel like if we didn't get like absolutely fucked over ping over ping as well During the the first game, I feel like I feel like The first game it would have been close to like something Sorry, I'm fucking dying Okay, I legitimately think that like the first game we had like an even out ping maybe something would have happened Something was not supposed to happen though.
It wasn't The thing is, it wasn't even supposed to happen We were supposed to get knocked out But we were just so in the zone and we were so in the fucking zone and we're like, yeah, let's just play the play Let's just let's just play we'll see how it happens and then what happened was that we fucking won Against an EU team too for the I feel so bad.
I was like cuz like I told them I was like, oh, yeah They're like, do you think you get to day two before and I was like, um Yeah, I'm pretty sure like I don't think I okay first off I said I don't think we're gonna make it to day two But if it happens,
we'll see
Guys I need you guys to know I played this was I calculated how many times I played How many times I personally played deadlock and I personally played deadlock like mmm, this would've been my eighth time playing deadlock This would this would that was my eighth time playing deadlock I was so surprised the show was able to do
I was very surprised with the things I could do when I When I did have ping on my side So, um, so I was like
I don't know what I'm doing, but I'm fucking I think my favorite part I think my favorite was when I canceled the Hayes all and then say jam was like, oh it got canceled He did not believe in me enough to do that
He didn't believe in me, but I canceled it out of replay.
Oh Yeah, I was very unhinged.
Um, I Was uh, I was definitely I still am I think like when I'm sick I don't have because when I stream I do have like a Filter in my head when I stream cuz I'm like, oh is this too much?
And then I'd be like, yeah, maybe I shouldn't say that But like ever since getting sick that filter has not worked in a while because like I'm too busy trying to survive Versus like don't say anything bad Oh My god, why am I so funny?
What's so funny that I make myself laugh anyway as I was saying So now I say every intrusive thought in my head that cut like in my head because usually I would you know, I don't say my intrusive thoughts too often, but Um But now now it's just flowing it's like literally free-flowing right now so like it's sort of scary It's sort of a little scary
Also, I realize um, oh my god, okay Like when we're playing that Dragon Ball Z game the sparking zero and the fucking the Vegeta great ape fight I don't realize that people were actually like, oh my god.
Did you guys know Bandai?
Bandai actually made a statement Regarding the great ape fight and they were like, please it's okay to lower the difficulty He is supposed to be hard.
I beat him without lowering the difficulty.
I did it And Then if you were like, here's some guides on how to beat the great ape and they were like talking about combos and everything And but I was like I flew up I flew up and I just started blasting
And I started blasting I did not need to understand the control Oh, I needed to know is how do I cheese this?
Last thing I didn't need combos.
I just started fucking blasting At least I just learned how to fly up and then I did that for the rest of my fucking
And Then I just kept doing it Even when my chat was like Doki you don't have to cheese anymore.
And I was like, it's too late You shouldn't have given me this power
This works that's all I can say it just fucking where I'm trying to find the tweet of of the I'm trying to find the tweet.
We're Bandai was like, please everybody you can lower the
I'm trying to find it.
Don't remember.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Oh, here it is.
Here you go.
Okay Here I thought it's really I thought that was really silly I refuse exactly I refuse I Refuse to lower the difficulty cuz I know the moment I lower that difficulty Chat would never be the same You will all look at me differently.
I know for the sake of my pride.
I couldn't do it.
I Know you would all lower.
I know you would all look every differently if I did I had to figure it out
So I had to and I thought that was really funny anyway, yeah Yeah, I'm pretty I don't have a filter right now and I'm saying every intrusive thoughts going in my head So like this is gonna be very risky for the next couple of days until I actually get better Which is gonna be hard because like I'm not giving myself actual time to recover full Cuz I'm like,
let me just keep streaming Let me just keep streaming cuz there's so many cool things to do this week But next week I'm definitely but next week I definitely have to chill out I'm gonna definitely chill out next week because Like I said From you know,
I afford so much social interaction.
There's been a lot of social interaction The last couple of weeks and I I want to I'm an introvert guys, I don't know I told you as many times I'm actually an introvert.
I just hide it really really well But like it's also different because I'm talking to a screen rather talking to a person I'm talking to an ad like if I have to look at somebody in the eye Like actual eyes and then like hang out with them like that's different But like talking via the screen is like it's not yeah,
it's not the same to me It feels like I'm you know, it feels like, you know, there's like a barrier towards somebody so like it doesn't feel the same as like Interacting IRL, but I am an introvert even then even with the barrier So like even with the barrier in between me and people it still sucks up a lot of energy.
So So like I definitely need a recharge Yeah, you guys you guys I know like 5% of you guys are real and then 95% of you are guys are like bots, right like
Like so my fans could like make me feel better right guy
Are we real?
Oh no, they're becoming self-aware.
I did not pay premium price for these bots guys.
Like please don't make them charge
All right, let's see I'm trying to see if there's any other Life updates that I have today for us.
Not really yesterday was so okay.
I like fucking Who's real and who's fake that's what a bot would say
Yesterday I mostly just Slept right after those two streams cuz I was so I was so fucking tired Afterwards cuz I was like, oh my god, that was like triple the social interaction yesterday But I really wanted to play a power simulator to talk to you guys and that's why I chose power simulator and just in time The Shrek DLC just came out today.
So I thought wow Let's check out the Shrek DLC because in honor of Shrek 5 that's gonna come out next year Mike Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you real fan here.
I think that's what a bot would say Technology is Improved I can't believe it Technology has come so far that like now now the bots are super chatting with my own money Please stop guys.
No guys.
Stop the super chats are coming out of my own wallet
No bots here, how the fuck did she know say no, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you I knew connecting my bank account to chat GPT was a bad idea.
I Hey power off simulator for those who don't know what Power wash simulator is it is basically like the crime scene cleaner but like, you know We're not cleaning blood anymore We're actually like we're actually cleaning like oh, let's do high fuck it.
Let's go Like what's the worst that could happen her famous last words?
Um Anyway, so it's basically like crime scene killer cleaner.
Sorry There's no killing involved in game, of course But there's it's basically we just clean we clean up dirt My office is a fucking mess, but instead of cleaning my office, I'm gonna clean up virtual I'm gonna clean a virtual environment to make myself feel better like
Okay, so, you know, I was really sick so like obviously I couldn't clean my office when I was really sick So there's like take out boxes and like water bottles everywhere And so like like on the first day of still actually getting better.
I You know got a trash bag and then I couldn't fill up all the trash in one trash bag, that's That's how bad it That's how bad it was So anyway, it's starting to it's starting It's not XQC Asmongold bad guys, like it's not there's no fucking rats here There was just a lot a lot of water bottles everywhere like a lot a lot of water bottles and then and then there's like there was like two bags of like Takeout bags and so like because there was a lot of water bottles.
It took up a lot of space so because of that Like the my one trash bag couldn't hold it hold everything up.
So instead of doing that instead of instead of doing that I Am I'm just gonna you know, I can't clean up my actual life So I'm just gonna clean up my virtual life because that's what video games all about escapism, yeah Guys, I'm swear.
I'm okay.
My life is not that much of a mess.
I swear JP.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm sorry Doki.
I've been but bot since the very beginning.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you Reason Nick.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Jen.
Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you God no.
Okay.
I would actually oh my god.
We're clean the city of Duloc.
Wait, what about um, oh We have to start in Duloc, but I want to clean Shrek's house, I don't fucking clean Farquaad's house All right, let's clean Farquaad's.
Oh wait, I didn't even read the thing.
What did it say?
Oh god I want to read the let's get back to the main menu.
I want to read the job.
Okay?
There you are What took you so long Encounter a curious and stubborn stain on the way as you are no doubt aware I'm soon to be made king by marrying the most beautiful damsel in the world Snow white.
No, wait, I rejected her.
It was the one after no matter The point is that the privilege of rescuing said mating from a dragonly abode was won by a fraudulent fraudulent Ogre, which led left the vanquished Knights here in Duloc somewhat aggrieved Consequently, they let vent their frustration Rampaging through the town on their way out.
I'm not having my bride to be his intimate procession soured by the unruly actions of Whatever that fucking word is ingrates.
Okay freaking Lord Farquaad.
All right, let's go Details.
Oh my god.
It's such a fucking mess.
All right, let's make sure our sensitivity is okay Let's lower the sense turn on some.
Oh, I forgot we'd turn on the music.
Did you guys see I that's crazy how Mr. Beast is like Does not care anymore about his reputation I don't know you guys saw but like He recently posted a video of him renting a movie theater To play talk to to play that that podcast of the talk to podcasts and then blasting KSI's music video in the speakers while eating lunch Lee I was like the fuck I was just like why like I'm like this is it's obviously rage bait like we all know that's just rage bait,
but like like I I just
I Don't know I'm just like why like you don't need a rage bait.
I don't understand
I'm like, why do you need to rage bait?
I I don't understand.
I couldn't like I couldn't Um, like in my head I just couldn't process it because it was just so confusing to me
I I don't know.
I just I feel like you already have so much like did you really need to?
Did you really need to rage bait like I?
Guess like I know something's like but the algorithm Doki the algorithm and Yeah, he's gone Downhill, so I I don't under I like I guess like any publicity is good publicity at that point but also like at the risk of his rep and he literally like self-destructed his reputation within within like Within like like three months actually His is yeah like within three months he actually like self-destructed he also I need putting music in bum bum But um,
but I don't know It's new.
Yeah, it's the fastest fall of I've ever seen Anyway, we're okay Let me make sure I don't know sound guys alive right now.
I Feel like this year has been the weirdest fucking year for it like we've had like several hurricane Like I feel like this year has definitely been the weirdest fucking year overall several hurricanes one of them named after Milton Fucking named Milton And then like okay audio Let's turn this down and then oh that is actually I don't know.
I don't know I just want to clean and then what is that?
Why is it yellow?
What the were they throwing what were they throwing that could be yellow eggs.
Oh, it's eggs Okay, I'm gonna say like oh I only know one thing that's yellow, but that's like oh my god.
I forgot eggs chickens exist.
I forgot you guys are You guys exist I'm sorry
I was like, holy shit.
Oh my god Why would they throw valuable food guys?
I don't understand.
Why would you ever throw food?
They're already poor They're peasants You just call me a chicken I mean you guys are practically like a chicken you guys are like half chicken half dragon at this point Like why are you yellow?
You guys are literally you guys literally come from eggs which came first the dragoon or the or the egg They're throwing dragoons nukes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Magister they give us super chat.
Thank you Yeah, what I had I lived through Dante's Inferno then Then be in that movie theater I just imagine they got paid a lot of money for that because that's what mr. B.
I'm just thinking like I'm just thinking like like I Guess like people it doesn't matter how much how bad is publicity is because in the how do I clean up that?
How how?
Why are there fucking stains up there?
What kind of oh my god.
Do I have ladders?
But I don't but oh I do.
Okay.
Thank God.
Oh, I can have extenders.
Okay.
Thank God Okay, I was gonna say why what am I gonna do?
I'll bring up a little bit.
Yeah Anyway life is I feel like life overall has been really fucking weird like I said rage bait fucking works because look at like KSI a load and Logan Paul and Jake Paul They've literally done everything that you should never do as a social media influencer except for except for I know okay,
this is like I'm trying to filter this except for one thing that gets you canceled forever like Oh, that's not true cuz dreams still exist never mind Never mind, I forgot you can't get canceled forever anymore cuz stream is still on the platform If you know,
you know if you
Okay, anyway anyway as I was saying as I as I was saying They've Jake and Logan Paul have done everything Possible.
We're like, you know, you should it do as a content creator and on so like, you know overall But they still have a platform So it's like it doesn't matter and I feel like people and mr Beast goes up to you and was like hey, you won't participate in a video to win like I don't know $500,000
it's still $500,000 Like are you like?
Yeah, he might be like a fucking terrible person right now But like are you really gonna say no to five?
Don't lie to me.
I know we don't have morality
Don't you think about the morals?
Like I feel like we'd all we're willing to take
We Take the money I Would actually well I would say no congratulations, you're you're literally the 1% right now
Yeah, like I feel like money is just like it's still $500,000 I I just realized like Okay, so like I went after like I was very curious.
I don't watch mr. Beast videos I find like I don't really care much about mr. Beast videos.
I think like I don't know.
There's just something It's just reality TV.
I feel like mr. Beast videos for me.
It's just like Reality TV shows but like on a YouTube format, but it's like it's not to me.
It's not like There's no stakes involved that to me that like makes me engage To watch it.
So I just treated it less like I don't know I just never got into his videos at all.
Even when his even when his reputation was like, all right, you know Yeah, it's definitely feels very.
Yeah.
Yeah, it feels very Scripted and like, um, it doesn't feel very genuine to me I feel like cuz it's not it's not genuine it's all like his videos are all about like trying to get the most amount of clicks and Trying to get the most amount of clicks and viewerships and numbers.
It's all about no, I mean as a content creator yeah, like Like numbers numbers numbers numbers is very important as a content creator But like it just felt so disingenuous sometimes like with what he's doing Um Like he knows the algorithm very very very well,
but like I can't I don't he doesn't have a Personality like and I remember I watched like an interview cuz I was curious there was like an interview from him and and he was like I tried to have no personality in my videos so that people Like what I don't remember what exactly the reason but like he even amidst that he's like,
yeah like I try to do these videos to not have a personality in there And I don't remember what the reason was I think it was so that like he's like a blank page for the viewers and stuff so they can focus on the content itself Like yeah, he's can be like the self insert I guess like like the self insert so like audiences can like put them put themselves in In there in his place and stuff like that and like since he has no personality in the video You focus on the event he's putting through versus like what he's doing He's just like the host but even hosts have personality But like... He... I don't know I could never get into him just cause like he just didn't feel like a fucking person.
like like he just he just didn't feel like a person at all to me.
His style felt like a brand.
Like um like a brand in uh, like a fucking human brand.
I think that's like how I would describe it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're a mix between a dragon and a chicken did a chicken and dragon like I'm You have a donkey and dragon to can do it like Almost I mean, we're literally playing Shrek like It's called no, it's called fucking evolution you idiot
It's called fucking evolution, where do you think it where you think happened to the dinosaurs guys?
Alright, okay You guys just gradually turn smaller and smaller and smaller until that you're like a punchable size
The ice age I like to order three cases of The meteorite doki.
What do you mean?
Yes, but some things guys if a meteorite cannot destroy like everything guys If a meteorite could destroy everything then how did fucking crocodiles survive?
I don't know if you guys notice but crocodiles and alligators were part of the meteorite They were there Like what the fuck do you mean they live through it take buried it they That's different they were in the water.
Oh, yeah, and water and water dinosaurs didn't exist back then
But the crocodiles existed
You don't understand doki the crocodiles they came from the meteorite and took them took the dinosaurs out
Then what cuz alligators just are smarter I don't fuck Why don't you ask your ancestors that like ask them why they couldn't live through the meteor, right?
Like
You're you are the worst, oh, thank you.
I hope that I'm not good at this cuz I I hope I'm not good at power washer So I don't have to do this as my real job The Megalodon shark it's still out there don't listen to them
But that's the thing no, it's supposed they're supposed to get smaller cuz it's like it's something to do with like global warming, too Wait, no, no, actually no global warming is making things bigger again.
No, sorry things are I Think is that is that it?
I don't know if I'm getting it confused global warming makes things bigger again and like And like if if we don't stop global warming the bugs are gonna the bugs are gonna get bigger again Yeah, no, it's true It's true That's the reason why Oh smaller No,
is it not?
Oh, it's oxygen concentration.
Oh, okay.
Thank God.
All right.
No, okay.
Never mind.
So we don't to care about globe
That'd be really fucked up Yogi's only reason to care about global warning is cuz she doesn't want the bugs to get bigger
Okay Well, yes, no that the bugs are bugs are getting a week I care I care but
Anyway the because we have less oxygen I mean it's still connected It's still connected Cuz like I technically like technically because like we're like
Like, you know, we're losing the trees so we're getting less oxygen so things are getting smaller now So yeah, things are getting smaller.
You guys just don't have enough oxygen, I guess Am I is this the only thing I have there?
Oh my god.
It is.
Oh My god, this is literally oh I have other nozzles.
Oh, thank God I'll get the turbo nozzle Okay Yeah, yeah, never mind let me not use it what what is it is it That's 40 degree nozzle.
Is that bigger?
Oh, it is.
It is bigger.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, that's what we needed We needed like more more range anyway But yeah, the more you know the more, you know, that's why insects used to be fucking huge I 70 I'm never unlocking.
I'm never unlocking Shrek Shrek's house.
I can't believe the first thing I have to clean is this fucking castle I literally only have done 7% of this Like
So me being smaller it was because yes, that's the reason you're Yes, you have found a new reason to blame for your height But they give us super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, you can finally blame global warming.
It was all climate change fault I can't believe it.
I'll never me.
I actually got out of the swamp.
I'll never make it plant more trees
Guys all I'm saying is that if you want to bring back the dinosaurs, you know what to do You know what to do.
Yeah, go that's that's what mr. B should have done You know He said like, you know plant more trees for the for the earth if he really wanted to plant if he really wanted to save The world you should have been like do you like dinosaurs?
Well, do you want to bring them back?
It's time to plant more trees.
So our chickens can grow back into dinosaurs
Dragoons fix the climate to make us big I Mean, I feel like was that law?
I feel like anybody I feel like that's how you get into the zoomers heart and the children Really just be like you like dinosaurs There's a lot of dinosaurs like there's like also like dinosaur enthusiasts are like really really dedicated So he was thinking too small exactly yo trash He was thinking way too small because I feel like if you tell people it's not lying because it's technically true Like it's just gonna take like a couple if you just omit the information That's just gonna take a couple of millions of years People will do it.
Just don't tell them like how long it's gonna take to get the dinos- dinos back there.
It might take like a couple million years, but we saved the world.
Exactly.
It's great motivation.
Don't doki.
As long as it's in the fine print, you know, like the tiny-ass fine print, it'll be fine.
People love dinosaurs.
It's the only way.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this graffiti?
I mean, oh, I actually watched the- by the way.
By- can I be- oh no, I don't know.
I- oh my gosh.
Oh, you're five.
You're like five years too late.
I don't think anybody wants to be Chris Pratt anymore.
I-
I - I - I- I- I - Thank you, thank you, Sharko.
I still- I can't believe it.
He got so much hate for those videos.
I feel like that hate wasn't justified, but like every- everything that happened to him now justified that hate that he received for doing charity- that's the thing.
I was like not really like, oh man, that's pretty fucked up, but like because of all the dumb fucking shit he did, like the hate was justified for the charity work he did.
Like, he did!
I just can't believe they got vindicated.
It's actually crazy.
Yeah, all his haters feel so vindicated now.
Oh my god, this is actually insane.
I've never seen somebody fall off that- that quickly before.
Of everything he's done.
Like, he- he was like super untouchable and then- and this- for some reason he was like, I'm gonna team up with Logan Paul and KSI.
Like, I-
I guess money is money.
I mean, he is getting sued by like a million different corporations, so I guess he needed the money, but still.
I don't know if you guys know this, but yeah, he's- yeah, he got sued by more things because of his- because of the- his IRL- the thing is, he's trying to do I- He's trying to do IRL Squid Game, and like, I feel like he like missed out on the message.
What Squid Game was?
I- I- I don't know, that's- is that- is that something?
Am I crazy for saying that?
I- I feel like he missed out on the entire message of Squid Game, and he's literally trying to do an IRL Squid Game.
And like, he act- literally endangered people's lives for too many years.
Apparently a lot of people got fucking hurt for- for participating in the IRL Squid Game.
And like- like, he's- he's like banned in Las Vegas.
Um, in like a Las Vegas studio because he got more people injured for the- his reality TV show.
Which is- which is fucking crazy.
Sorry, I spent like- I realized I spent 30 minutes talking about MrBeast, but I'm trying to be relevant about current times right now.
Um, to IRL for IRL.
Yeah, like, there's- he tried to contract some of the filming, um, some of the, uh, filming to some Las Vegas production company.
And then the Las Vegas production company sued- like, I don't know if he got sued by them, or like, they- he got banned from ever working with them.
That's what I remember reading.
Um, Angel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, hey Doki, as a Floridian Dragoon with no power internet, have some money.
Also, I was debating flipping off the hurricane.
Tell him to go back.
No, don't go outside, Angel, no!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Angel, no!
Don't go outside!
If you're gonna flip it off, do it, like, against the window.
That's what windows are for!
Did I clean this correctly?
Oh, I'm supposed to clean the graffiti as well?
Oh!
Okay, that makes sense, actually.
I- I- No, no, that- that makes sense.
Okay, that means I need to change the nozzle.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, I can, like, lie down.
But why would I lie down when I can- Ooh!
When I can just, like, look down.
I don't understand.
Wait, there was- wait, tur- oh yeah, the show did!
But how do I change my nozzle?
Oh, I can right-click!
I don't have to- oh my god, this changes everything!
Wait, aim mode?
Oh my god, wait, this changes everything!
Wait, oh my god, thank you, tutorial!
Actually, no.
I can- I literally can just right-click and it'll...
Um...
Wait, how do I- what was the button for- Guys, what was the button to open the- open the, uh...
The quick select again, guys?
I don't remember.
Guys, what was the button to open the quick select?
I'm becoming stronger, guys.
What was the button again?
I don't remember.
The- the change the nozzle thing.
The fast change of the nozzle.
Is it not yeet?
No, it's this, but there was like a shortcut.
There was an actual shortcut for it.
Was it R?
No, no, that changes the thing.
Two?
Oh, it's two!
Okay, nice.
Uh... what's this?
Oh yeah, that's like baby mode.
Um, what was I using?
Was I using this?
Okay, this is faster.
To get rid of the graffiti, because you're stronger.
But yeah, I actually watched Shrek the Musical, um, on my friend's birthday.
Um, uh, cause like she, uh, sorry, he, um...
He lives in New York, and I remember, uh, I remember like he like, uh, invited me to watch his, uh, watch Shrek the Musical for his birthday.
Live on broad- was it on Broadway?
I don't even remember.
There's so many ways.
There's like Broadway, and then there's off-Broadway.
I haven't watched a musical in a long-ass time, cause I haven't been in New York in a long time.
I think the very last musical I watched in Broadway was, uh, the one about pies.
I don't remember what it was.
I would like look up, and look up like, oh, like, best musicals of the year at that time.
Cause then, cause I would, I have to go to New York for like, conferences back in, uh, uh, university.
So like, um, for like academic trips and stuff in universities.
So like, I get to, I get to like, uh, you know, so since I'm in New York, I'll be like, oh yeah, let's, let's go fucking watch a musical!
And I, I don't watch like the, I, I try, I avoid the classic, like, you know, there's like, you know, you can, there's classic like, like, Les Miserables and Cats.
Oh God, I watch Cats in Asia.
I remember watching Cats in Asia when they did like a world tour.
Um, Cats, or like, what was it?
Or Chicago, I don't watch those.
I try to go for like, I try to go for like, the newer shows.
I go for the newer shows cause I know the classics will always come back, you know.
Cause the show, the musicals are already like, so fucking old that they always bring them back.
Um, they always bring them back.
And then the original cast, the original cast will be like, you know, either dead or like, really old.
So it's like, you know, there's no point in actually like, um, I feel like for me, I could always watch those whenever.
Just cause they always bring back, they always bring those shows back.
But a lot of like, the really good ones, um, of our generation, of our times, they never, they won't bring it back.
Like, they won't bring it back until many, many years later.
Um, and like, it won't be with the original cast.
So like, I usually choose the ones that like, are like, the current popular musical.
That are considered like, oh like, really good now.
Um, um, just cause like, the original cast is still there.
Um, you know, and I get to experience the original cast live.
And, um, and like, um, and like, you know, normally they won't even do world tours too.
Like, like, I know like, cause I got, I watched like, Book of Mormon.
I watched Book of Mormon with the original cast.
When, what's his name, Josh whatever.
The voice of Olaf when he was still there.
I watched the Book of Mormon, um, with the original cast.
I watched the, that pie musical with the original cast.
I remember that musical, that musical was really good, I just forgot the name.
Um, it was like, at that time, it was like, really popular.
I watched the, um, um, what was it?
Uh, Hamilton with the original cast.
You know, when I said like, when, um, what's his name, Lin-Manuel.
When Lin-Manuel fucking first showed up, the audience clapped for like, ten fucking minutes.
For just, he was just standing there.
I, I just, I was like, really.
Okay, my ten minutes might be like an exaggeration.
But by God, it felt like fucking ten minutes of clapping.
Um, I watched the, um, the, uh, uh, like Hamilton with the original cast.
With Lin-Manuel there.
Um, and then I think, I know I did one more.
Oh, I did School of Rock, yeah.
School of Rock with the original cast.
Um, and the guy who played School of Rock.
It was crazy to find out that the guy who was in School of Rock.
I wish I could watch Beetlejuice.
I really wanted to check out Beetlejuice.
But obviously, like, you know, when Beetlejuice came out, like, um, I've been super fucking busy.
So I never got a chance to.
I think Beetlejuice is the one musical I wish I got to experience.
Yes, there's a School of Rock musical.
It's really, really good.
Oh, and I watched Matilda.
Matilda with the original cast.
Matilda is so, oh my god.
Okay, guys, I'm gonna get demonetized.
I don't care.
Okay, this is gonna be my second VOD in a row where I get demonetized.
It's alright.
Okay, this, I, I don't know why, but I really, I really, I really like this song.
Um, okay, what was it?
Is it, is it a school song?
Or, like, nani?
I think it's, like, one or, I think it's either of these.
This song, I was obsessed with this song for, um, I was obsessed with this song.
Is it?
This, this was, like, the first music I watched in New York.
I haven't even met.
A bit orangery.
Oh my gosh, she's so talented.
Got to be a little bit naughty.
This wasn't, oh no.
I wish I was a singer.
I love musicals.
I think this is, like, the one thing, um, I mean, I could take singing lessons.
But, like, I feel like I'll never be able to sing, like, you know, like, at that, at that level.
But I do wish, if I could, if I could, like, remove one of my talent points, I would, I would, like, I would actually remove talent points just to be able to sing.
Cause I fucking love musicals so much.
If I could sing, I would do musical karaokes all the time.
Oh,
the next song is the one that I like the most.
This one is also good.
I remember listening to this in the next song.
That's strange.
That's not right.
It's not right.
I'm so sorry if this VOD ends up being blocked in certain countries.
I'm sorry.
I really want to listen to a musical soundtrack.
I tried, I was like, alright, Doki, today...
Oh, it's not fair.
I tried, I was like, I was like, okay, Doki, this time, this time, you are not gonna get a VOD demonetized, Doki.
You had, you already had a VOD demonetized yesterday, Doki.
You need, you make jokes about ad revenue, but Doki, you can't keep doing this.
I can't help it.
And then I'm like, musicals.
I'm just like, but like, musical soundtrack, though.
Oh, this one, this one, my favorite.
This is one of my favorite songs.
I just love it.
I can't help it.
I just want to share my love for musicals.
Says I'm a miracle.
This is one of my favorite songs from the Matilda.
The Matilda, I remember the one thing I loved about the Matilda musical was the, was the production design was really good.
Angel, mom says I'm an angel.
This is one of my favorite songs.
And then you guys don't know, they're doing the alphabet right now.
Like this.
Oh, my God.
Watching this, watching this live was so cool.
You
know what I'm gonna say?
I don't like musical movies.
Except for like, there's a few exceptions.
There's a very, very, very few exceptions.
I meant like, like, like real live action musical movies.
Because they don't capture the musicals quite right.
Because I'm talking about like the current generation of musical movies.
Because I also, I really like the, I like Mean Girls the musical because I listened to the soundtrack of the original theater recording, Broadway recording.
And then the, oh, the movie version was so fucking bad.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad the movie version of, I hope Wicked is not that bad.
I hope Wicked the musical movie is not bad.
But like, I don't know.
I don't know.
It's the one where Aria Grande started dating the guy who was in the Spongebob musical.
That still blows my mind.
She fell in love with that actor who was Spongebob in the Spongebob musical.
And started dating him because of the Wicked movie.
Yeah, the more, yeah, you guys didn't know?
You guys...
Yeah, no!
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, guys, let me play my BGM.
I can't believe you guys didn't know that!
Alright, so, okay, Spongebob musical.
By the way, the Spongebob musical is really good.
I watched the, I didn't get to watch the, that was one of the musicals I regret not knowing, not being able to watch.
Because like, the Spongebob musical is like really, really, really good.
Um...
And, and, um, and, uh...
Wait, she isn't dating him?
She isn't?
When, what?
Really?
That was debunked?
Oh my god, a complete timeline.
The last time I checked was like two months ago.
The last time, the last time I checked, when did they break up?
I was like, I was so curious.
Okay, I'm gonna check, okay.
June 10th, 2024.
Aria Grande and Ethan Slater take date night to the rink.
The couple was photographed at the Stanley...
Wait, when did it get debunked?
I literally looked up!
I'm looking up the fucking timeline!
Like...
Oh my god, I'm literally...
Oh my god, the link was so long that it disappeared.
I...
Oh, speak sound!
Oh, there it is!
It was...
Alright, following the...
Okay, alright.
Aria Grande on the most disappointing part of pub...
September!
Okay, that was the...
I would did not...
I did not...
I did not look at...
I did not check on September, guys.
I did not...
I didn't check in September.
The last update was in July.
That was the last update I saw.
I didn't realize in September, she made another update.
Alright.
Okay, I'm checking.
I've been pictured together on several occasions.
The two were pictured together.
Where does she say it doesn't...
Over the...
Where does it say that you're not together?
Where did it debunk?
There could be less accurate depiction of a human...
There's nothing that says they're, like, not...
Okay, no one on Earth tries harder or spreads themselves thinner.
This Earth would...
That's something...
Where?
After a couple...
The couple...
Confirmed their relationship in July 20...
It was!
I'm reading this right now!
I'm literally reading this!
It says they're a couple!
To me, they'll always be.
Oh my god.
Okay, anyway...
As I was...
WHO IS CURRENTLY DATING ARIANA GRANDE?!
What was this conversation?
Ariana Grande is dating the guy in Spongebob.
The guy...
Is dating the guy who played Spongebob in the Spongebob musical.
So this is what he looks like.
By the way, the Spongebob musical is...
I fucking knew it.
I knew I was right.
I was curious.
Because I was like...
Oh my god.
Look, I like to keep up with the news.
This is the news I keep up with.
She's technically dating Spongebob.
Yes.
For those who don't know...
The Spongebob musical is actually really fucking good.
And like...
Oh man.
I'm sad.
I'm a little sad now.
I can't believe...
I let my love for musicals...
Got me another Vaati monetized.
I...
Because now I'm back to public domain.
Public domain VGN.
Anyway...
As I was saying...
I would highly suggest checking out the Spongebob musical.
If you like musicals.
Because it has like...
The most ridiculous...
The most ridiculous like...
People working on it.
Who wrote the songs.
What was it?
Okay.
So we have...
Yeah!
He did!
He did a song!
I think it was for Plankton.
Like No Control.
Spongebob.
Wait.
Who sang this one?
No Control.
Appears on...
Oh no.
It was from the...
Yeah.
It was from the Citizens of Bikini Bottom.
John.
Yeah!
Guys.
You guys.
Yeah!
No.
I'm serious.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
He...
Okay.
I think like...
You know what's even crazier?
The song he wrote for Spongebob.
Might have been one of the last things he's done.
Like...
After he died.
That's actually crazy!
Like...
No!
He wrote the song and...
He wrote the song and then like...
The song got released in 2017.
It got...
Like...
You know like...
Post...
It was like posthumously.
Like it got released afterwards.
After he died.
Like...
That's actually crazy.
To think about.
One of his final works...
Was that he wrote it for Spongebob.
No!
It's actually good!
The...
Like legitimate...
Look at the fucking tracks!
Okay.
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking giving you guys the links.
Look at the...
The...
The people that wrote songs in there.
It's...
Almost every song is written by a different composer.
Like a different famous composer.
Bro, they won so many awards!
That's also the reason why I wanted to...
Wait, why...
Why are they only nominated?
72nd...
Who won?
Who took over?
The fuck is...
Okay, let's see.
Spongebob.
What the fuck is the band's visit?
The band's visit beats Spongebob.
That's crazy.
I don't even know what they are.
I don't even know what that musical is!
Alright, anyway.
Back to cleaning.
Sorry.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it to the swamp.
Guys.
Guys, I don't think we're gonna make it to the...
I don't...
I...
I think...
I think it's too late.
Oh yeah, the Krabby Patty collaboration...
With Wendy's.
I love how people are like, It's good, but it's just not the same.
And then people were like, Of course it's not the same.
It's not made by Spongebob.
It was like, People were like, Oh my god, it's so lore accurate.
The Krabby Patty just doesn't have the same feeling Because it's got...
It got like, mass produced by greedy corporations.
Just a day single.
Oh my god.
I've never had a Wendy's burger.
I...
I tend to like, Avoid fast food in general.
Okay.
Um...
What was it?
I tend...
Yeah, I tend to avoid fast food in general.
Except for chicken nuggies.
That's like, the only thing.
But I haven't...
I haven't...
I haven't had...
I...
I haven't had chicken nuggies in forever though.
But I tend to avoid fast food.
I've been like, Um...
I just get like, Regular food.
Because I don't need...
I don't...
I don't need things to be fast.
But I've never...
I've never had a Wendy's before.
I've had Burger King.
I mean, I was like...
I had Burger King, But even then, Burger King has been like, Long...
Long time.
We have like, White Spot.
But like...
Um...
But like, That's not really fast food.
That's just like, A family...
Chain restaurant.
I don't even know if it's called family chain restaurant.
I...
I don't even know if that's the right word.
Um...
But I haven't had like, Fast food in a long time.
I just thought it was funny that...
Wendy's got the...
Wendy's got the Krabby Patty promotion.
Classic Millionaire Doki!
So unrelatable!
Yeah, like, I would order...
From like, The...
Um...
The...
That you have to send in your like, Tax returns.
And your bank information to get access to.
And that opens up the exclusive...
Um...
Restaurants that only like, Michelin stars are in.
Like, I know like, You might be like, Oh...
Um...
Why the fucking Lord Farquaad texted me about his day?
I'm not your friend.
I'm just a...
Fucking...
I'm just hired to do your...
Your job.
Anyway, the...
LMAO Yeah, so like.
I'm sorry like, Aw, it's so hard to be me sometimes.
LMAO So...
So I have my platinum Uber Eats.
And...
We ordered.
We...
And that's where all the Michelin stars put their...
Uh...
Put their takeout order.
Like, you must be like, But Doki, Michelin stars don't do takeout.
Don't do like...
Order out.
That's a joke.
We must destroy the upper class.
Rise up, dragons!
Anonymous, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here, Doki, go buy some nuggets.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Eat the rich and we're talking about eating.
We might as well eat the rich.
It's time to bring back the only good thing the French gave us, the French Revolution.
Anyway, clean, clean, clean.
Clean, clean, clean.
Is there like anything else I can clean that's not eggs and dirt?
Like, why are they wasting such good fucking eggs?
Oh my god, why are they wasting such good fucking eggs?
Mr. Beast about to be Mr. Beast.
Can I complete the job with like 50%?
Oh, hey, look, there's like a bunch of Lord Farquaad's merchandising.
I miss classic Dreamworks.
Classic Dreamworks was all about like, like making fun of Disney, but now they became Disney.
Shrek, I don't know if you guys know this, but like Shrek was all about like making fun of Puss in Boots 2 was really, really good.
It just sucks that, you know, they went back to the same formula after that, like...
I love Puss in Boots 2, not because of like Okay, there was only one reason why I really love Puss in- like everybody would be like, oh, the animation.
Was it the animation?
Was it the, umm Was it the way they depicted anxiety so fucking?
Okay, I don't know what that- why that was such a fucking trend?
But like, at one point in like- at one point, everybody was like, oh my god, Like panic attacks so fucking like oh my god this movie makes depicting panic attacks So fucking relatable and accurate ever.
That's all everybody would talk about like everybody would be like Oh my god, this movie is good because look at how they portray panic attacks like what?
Like everybody kept talking about panic attacks in animation, I'm like bro, what the fuck like
Yeah, yeah, so like yeah, Puss had a panic attack in Puss in Boots 2 and everybody was like, oh my god That's so real.
That's so good.
And then and then every other Every other fucking movie start animation movie had panic attacks for some fucking reason People are like yeah Puss in Boots did it well, but did it do as well as like oh my god What was the other movie that had panic attacks like was it turning red?
Yeah, but what about turning red's panic attack, huh?
Anyway, anyway the reason why I really I really Oh, yeah inside out too.
Yeah.
What about like inside out 2's panic attack?
Like what the fuck like animation movies are not just about panic attacks guys It's not it's not the panic attacks guys, that's not what movies are about
What I love about About Puss in Boots 2 Was the fact that they gave us a villain that was just pure evil and I love it that like he has zero Redeemable qualities and he it was so fucking funny But what was his name Puss in Boots What was the villains name I forgot what was his name,
uh, Jack Horner.
Yeah, Jack Jack Horner I love Jack Horner, though.
I think he is literally one of like he's like the best the The best villain that's ever been in a movie and I love I love everything about him And I just want more of that.
I just want a villain That's just evil and he has zero redeeming qualities and like like he has no reason to be evil He just likes to be evil for the sake of being evil You're a redeemable monster
He was like, how did you turn to be evil?
How did you become evil?
Oh, I just have a loving family incredibly rich like
You use this crap like that He's so relatable guys, he's oh my god Jack Horner is just so relatable and that's why he's my favorite character
So real I
Think good locks was a fucking terror.
I had terror like terrible Villain, but it's alright.
She got she got What was it overlooked over because of Jack Horner?
I didn't like the Goldilocks edition of the story I feel like the Goldilocks addition to the story was useless.
I am Like I know she wasn't like the villain villain.
She was like more like the what's the word then what Deadpool is?
Um what's that word when you're not the antagonist you're the You're the redeemable Antagonist the anti-hero.
Yeah.
She was more like an anti-hero than a than a than the antagonist of the movie, but I just didn't feel like her addition to the Story was I didn't feel like her addition to the story was Was like it added anything.
I just don't think she added much to the to the movie itself
Yeah, I just didn't think she added much I also like wasn't really a big fan of the voice actress Portrayal of her because I feel like she was very stiff Versus I think the the other voice actors and voice actresses were so good in The movie that like when she said anything it just paled in comparison She just was like she just wasn't as good as a voice actor as the other people in the movie And the Bears were good I like the Bears I think the Bears were good That's how I felt about Goldilocks other than that like Jack Horner was my favorite part All right,
I'm gonna do it to give like a I'm gonna give like a Controversial opinion I did personally I'm gonna say it.
I'm gonna say it guys.
I'm gonna say it.
I I Watch Deadpool versus Wolverine and I think it was average
There I said it I personally think that movie was just
I Just think that like there was it was just It was just cameo bait the movie
That's all I felt about it I was like Oh, Jesus Christ, uh, what's his name?
Oh my god, um, the guy who plays Wolverine, he's so fucking old now.
Like, oh my god, he's so- Oh my god, he's- let him rest, please.
Like, but also, um, but also the fact that, like, it was literally just cameo, cameo, cameo, um, Hey, you up- hey, you remember this reference?
Yeah, let's bring it back.
And, oh my god, what about this reference?
Until he's 90, yeah.
You remember that reference?
Oh my god, yeah, from that other movie we had?
Oh my-
Yeah, I know Wolverine's supposed to be old, but he's not supposed to be, like, he's not supposed to, like, age that fast, if you remember.
So, like, there was no actual stories.
I think, like, that's basically the Deadpool formula.
Like, I think, like, at that point, I should remember that that's, like, the Deadpool formula, where, like, you know, Deadpool is all about being, like, referential.
And, like, um, current and stuff, because that's, like, you know, he's breaking the- he's breaking the fourth wall.
And, um, and, like, he's supposed- like, that's his- but then, like, it's three times of the same thing.
Like, you know, you know, like, the first time, you're, like, oh, yeah, that's funny, like, because it's, like, new.
The second time, you're, like, oh, haha.
Yeah, wait, no, this is the fourth one, right?
Or is it the third one?
I already lost track of how many Deadpool movies he's made.
Like, I already- I already- okay, third.
The second time, you're, like, oh, like, oh, haha, like, you know, back at it again.
But then, the third time, I was, like, oh, alright, we're- we're back- back- I guess- I guess we're- we're doing it again!
But we're even- but now Disney's involved, which I think that's also why, because Disney is also involved now.
So, like, it lost a little- like, I know people are, like, oh my god, he gets to be in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
But, like, I felt like it did lose a little bit of the charm, also.
So, he is James!
To be fair, I didn't watch fully the second movie.
I watched the- I liked the first movie, because, like, I felt like there was more of a story in the first movie.
The third movie, there was no story, I think.
There was not no story, but a lack of a story.
But, like...
But Deadpool and Wolverine have really good chemistry together, which is, like, what's- which is basically what's, like, you know...
What's, like, saving the movie in general.
It saved the movie because of, like, their chemistry together.
But I didn't, you know- I think I also got overhyped, because I saw so many people being, like, oh my god, it's, like, one of the- it was such a good- like, oh my god, it became the number one R-rated movie of all time.
And, like, oh my god, it's still doing so fucking well and everything.
And then, oh my god, bye bye bye ba-bum-ba-da-da-da-da-da-da!
And everybody's talking about the, um, bye bye bye scene, which was only in the beginning.
And then, um...
And then every- so then I think I went in with the movie already, like, super hyped up.
So then when I swatched it, I was just like, oh, it's- it's- it's just...
It was just average to me.
It's- I think- oh my god, the craziest part about that song being in the- I don't know if you guys saw that, but they literally renamed the song to be, like, um...
What was the song- is it the song title?
Bye Bye Bye?
I don't remember.
What was the song title for that?
Was it also Bye Bye Bye?
But, like, they renamed the song- the YouTube link of the song- the YouTube version of the song to, like, be, like, Bye Bye Bye from Deadpool.
Like, I was like, what do you mean from Deadpool?
Like, that song came out 20 plus years ago.
Like...
Like, they literally renamed with the origin of the song.
I don't know if they renamed it back.
That's a joke, so...
It's where- it's the clicks.
They had to make sure people know it was from- it's the one from Deadpool.
From Dead- by Deadpool from Fortnite.
That's so funny, I can't believe they- That's so funny and, like, smart for them to do.
It's from Deadpool- it was created just for Deadpool.
Anyway, I don't know, guys, I think, like, everybody knows that's not actually Ryan Reynolds that danced to that.
He is not...
He's- he's, like, he's a good actor, but, like, no, actually...
Okay, I won't- okay, I said it before, he's not necessarily a good actor.
He's just really good at playing himself.
He's not good at- he's not, like, the best actor.
He's just really good at being himself.
And he's at the point- he's at the- he's at- he's at the point where, like, people are okay with him playing himself.
But at one point, he's gonna hit that spot.
He's gonna hit that juicy spot, the Chris Pratt spot, and Jack Black spot, where people are gonna get very tired of him playing himself.
He's still at his honeymoon phase right now.
People still like that he's playing himself, guys.
But I bet you in five years, within five years, If- People are gonna be like, oh, another Ryan Reynolds movie where he plays himself?
It's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen, guys.
In five years, guys, I can see the future.
In five years, this is where it's gonna hit.
I can see his career Exploding, just like Jack Black.
If it can- okay, not- guys, I don't think anybody had it in their 2024 bingo for- for Jack Black's career to explode.
Like, I don't think anybody foresee that.
Like, if it could happen to Jack Black, it can absolutely happen to Ryan Reynolds.
Jack Black was fucking untouchable.
I Still like Jack Black, yeah, but now he's like a joke now.
Which is something nobody would have ever expected, you know?
Nobody would have expected that to happen to him because everybody was always like, oh my god, you know, like, you know, they're all like, oh my god, like, haha.
Oh my god, he's so funny, and like, playing himself.
It's a casting problem.
It's- it's all about, um, the board members.
It's always about board members.
Board members don't care about- board members don't care about, like, what's an actual good choice.
They just care about, like, money.
Because it's always about money.
It's like how I saw that- I saw there was a tweet about, um, so, you know, like, X-Men, uh, the director that did the X-Men movies, the director that did the X-Men movies, and he, like, he did the first X-Men movie, and then he did- but then he, like,
dropped out, and it dropped out for the second and third X-Men movie, I believe.
Um, and there was, like, a new thing came out.
A new, like, thing came out that got leaked.
Well, not leaked, but he, like, exposed something about, um, he exposed something about the, uh, like, you know, Hollywood and stuff, and basically, like, he was saying how, um, he decided- he was supposed to direct the sequel to First Class.
Was it sequel?
No, he was supposed to direct the third X-Men movie, and, um, and then he found out that, in order to get Hal Berry to play Storm in the third movie, they sent her a fake script, where she was heavily involved in the movie just to get her to sign the contract,
and then after she signed the contract, they threw away the script.
And gave her the real script.
Yeah, and I was like, bro, that's fucked up.
That's so...
That's...
That's so fucked up!
Like, that's illegal.
Not in Hollywood, baby!
Cause they could just be like, oh, the script got rewrote.
Yeah.
They could've been like, they could be like, oh yeah, the script got, like, rewritten.
I'm so sorry, we have to cut your scenes.
Like, your scenes became deleted and stuff.
Um, so, and then the director, um...
And then the director was like, I'm out.
Like, I, like, he was like, he found out, the director found out, and was like, yeah, I'm...
I'm out.
I can't, I don't wanna work in those conditions.
Yeah, that's just Hollywood.
It's, like, super corrupt.
Yeah, cause, like, she never, she hasn't signed yet, so, like, it was like, you know, like, actors would get sent scripts and stuff to, like, you know, cause they're like, oh, I don't know if I wanna sign, I wanna look at the script first to see, like,
if it's something I wanna do, and then, um, um, and then, like, obviously, you know, they send her, they, they try to send her a fake script so that, like, where she's heavily involved in the movie, just to make sure she signs.
Oh, yeah, is there a castle?
There's no castle.
Bro, I can't even get to the castle.
What do you mean?
I'm too fucking poor to reach the castle.
This is the poor, this is where the, the, the poor district is.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, where SheHawkMovies was originally supposed to be in Deadpool 3, Ryan Reynolds rejected her, oh my god.
To be fair, I won't be surprised if, like, a lot of people wanted to be in that movie.
I won't be surprised, cause I feel like, you know, that's something that, that's something that, like, people, um, I feel like a lot of actors and actresses would wanna be in just for the sake of, like, they know it's gonna be a really big movie, and that it's gonna,
it's gonna do really well.
So, like, I'm not surprised he would, like, he had to, like, pick and choose.
The production looked really fun?
Ah, I can see that.
I can see the production being really fun.
Yeah.
How old is Tobey Maguire?
Anyway, I'm actually, oh my god, guys, let's age all of us.
Let's make you all feel old.
Oh my god, he's, like, 49?
Okay, he's not as old as I thought.
How does he still look so young?
Tobey Maguire, now.
Oh my god.
Bro, he looks so, he still has, like, like, that Spider-Man look.
He's, like, almost 50, but he looks, he looks so young.
Guys, did you guys hear Kingdom Hearts?
Kingdom Hearts 4 might be the last Kingdom Hearts in the series.
The funniest shit I've read about Kingdom Hearts is that, I don't know, I think you guys told me about it.
I don't know if it's, no.
Actually, no.
I don't remember if you guys told me about it, but, like, the funniest shit I heard about Kingdom Hearts is that the creator slash director of Kingdom Hearts has to watch YouTube videos of, like, YouTube Lore Explained videos just to remember what the fuck was going on.
So he... I'm just like, even you don't remember what's going on?
What do you mean?
He, like, he has to... Bro, like, what do you mean you have to watch, like, do you not have your own fucking spark notes of, like, what you were fucking cooking?
Like...
It was... Yeah.
He has to watch, like, YouTube Explained videos of Kingdom Hearts to, like, remember what the fuck he wrote.
Like, I'm just like... That's just crazy.
I don't know.
I don't know about you guys, but...
He forgot the recipe.
I'm like, what if, like... I'm just thinking, like, what if there was some plot points that were supposed to be explained later, but he forgot?
Like, I don't think that YouTube Explained people remember those plot points.
Like, I'm just never told to them.
He's like, what was the lore again?
Like, I just... That just blows my mind.
That just really blows my mind that he has to re-watch, like, he has to watch other content creators' videos to remember what he wrote.
Surely the YouTubers got most of what I was trying to do.
What was the lore I made up?
I... That's what I'm saying!
Like, I'm just... Don't they have, like, a fucking file?
No!
Like, don't they have, like, a file?
So many years of lore, too.
Oh my god.
That, like, blew my mind.
Anyway, Kingdom Hearts 4 is apparently the last Kingdom Hearts.
Until, like, I don't know, until they want more money or something.
Until they're, like, 80 years in the future.
Sora... Not 80, sorry, 500... I was gonna say Sora is dead after 80 years.
I'm like, oh, that's...
500 years in the future, there is now a new Keyblade wielder, and now we gotta do this all over again.
Kingdom Hearts 5.
I hate it!
As long as they... Maybe they'll do it all over again.
Spoilers, Stokie!
Spoilers, they just signed the contract!
You're not supposed to say that!
Disney wants it to end badly?
I don't think Disney really... I don't think so.
Money is money.
I don't think Disney wants it to end badly.
I think they just, um...
They just... The only thing Disney doesn't like is that... I think, like, Disney doesn't like violence with their characters.
They...
So, I don't know, please use... No!
Was it actually better if I used a shorter?
Is it faster?
I can't tell.
I actually can't tell.
I don't know, maybe I've been, like, debuffing myself this entire time.
Disney is just business, yeah.
Disney is just... Then why did they kill Goofy in Kingdom Hearts 2?
Because it's funny.
Because back then, Disney didn't care as much about death, but now they do.
No, actually, no.
No, Ashman, Disney back then, they loved character death, as long as it progressed the plot.
That's all they liked to do.
Like, if they can, they will kill off an entire cast, if it meant it will give the main protagonist some sort of character building.
Disney's just sad?
Disney's just too big.
Disney is too big to do something wrong, that they'd rather do... They'd rather make an incredibly mediocre and forgettable movie, than a really, really...
Than something that is too experimental, that will get them cancelled.
Because, yeah, they fucked up with Star Wars, but it's not cancellable, it's just a bad movie.
But they'd rather do that, than, like, experiment with the formula, to risk getting, like, cancelled in something.
Because they don't like taking risks.
Because at best, they can just put the movie as a tax write-off.
Which is basically what they do, anyway.
Which is what companies do.
Star Wars is only alive via Nostalgia Bait.
And Grogu.
And Baby Yoda.
That's literally it.
Nostalgia Bait and Baby Yoda, that's all we have from Star Wars.
Oh, my song stopped playing.
It paused, because they were like, are you alive?
Yes, YouTube, I am.
Mandalorian was great, somebody didn't watch season 3.
That's all I'll say.
No!
Don't say that, I watched season 2!
Wait, who said season Mandalorian?
Just stop at season 2, that's all I'll tell you.
Just stop.
Just stop at season 2.
That's all you need to know.
Rest in peace, that one guy.
It's just... it's just not...
Okay, like...
Also, I don't know...
I don't know, the current trend in movies is that they remove every possible colors.
In color design.
I actually miss like...
Oh, my God, I miss when movies actually had color in it.
Now everything is like, dark and like...
Dark and you can't see jack shit.
Yeah, the color grading is fucking terrible now.
Yeah, most movies just look so dull.
It's just not...
It just doesn't look fun no...
I don't...
That's why I don't watch movies anymore.
I used to watch...
I just watch animation, because it's the only way I can get some form of color in like...
Like, some form of like...
Actual, good color grading.
And like, set composition and everything.
So like, I rarely watch like, live action movies these days.
I mostly just watch animated movies.
Oh, yeah!
I saw the Until Dawn remake.
That's cool.
They...
Okay, so like, Until Dawn is like, known for like, the...
The...
Oh, my God, I'm never gonna make it to this one.
We're at 37?!
All I've been doing is cleaning!
Like, what do you want me...
Oh, my God.
Okay, wide nozzle.
Where the fuck is the wide nozzle?
I...
What is...
Is this wide enough?
Okay.
Anyway...
What was I...
What was I saying?
Guys, I don't remember what I was saying.
I just can't believe I've only done 37%.
I...
I can't believe...
Oh, yeah!
So like, Until Dawn...
The entire reputation about...
Like, um...
Reputation with Until Dawn regarding like, it's aesthetic is that it's blue.
They took away the blue.
They actually...
They took away the blue!
Like...
I was like...
Did you guys see that?
Did you guys see...
Okay, I...
Okay, let me see if I can find the link.
I was actually...
What the fuck did they...
Like...
Like, I can't believe they did...
I can't believe they took away the blue!
It's gone!
Look!
It's not blue anymore!
Like, I'm like...
What happened?
And why is it harder to read?
Like...
I was like...
Oh my God!
She took the blue in the top four!
I'll post the link again.
Like, I'm just like...
Why is it not blue anymore?
That's the whole point!
It's supposed to be blue!
Like, it's supposed to be blue!
I don't...
It's not blue anymore!
Congratulations!
How is this a remake?
Like...
Like, the fucking...
The dev team was just like...
You know what?
I hate the color blue!
Like...
It looks so wack!
They also made...
What's his name?
The...
The Sammy Remake guy...
Actor...
Like, super expressive...
And it's so fucking creepy!
Like, Josh...
They made Josh...
Josh so fucking expressive...
And it's so creepy!
I don't like it!
Like, Josh looks like...
Okay...
Josh...
Until...
Oh yeah, Remi...
Remi, yeah...
Remi Malek, yeah...
Until Dawn...
It just doesn't...
It doesn't feel right!
It just...
Oh my God!
He just...
It just doesn't feel right!
Oh my God!
I don't know if...
I can't...
I don't know where...
There was a video of it...
But I can't...
Remember where it was...
Somebody will find it...
Mod, do you remember the video?
Because I don't...
But he was just like...
He just looks super uncanny...
It just looks like...
It just looks so fucking...
It just looks so weird...
It doesn't even look like the actor anymore who played him...
Imagine remaking a game into a worse experience...
Oh, ducking everyday...
They're literally...
Remaking games that don't even need a remake...
It's just the cash grab...
Like all the remasters...
Yeah...
I feel like...
If you're gonna remaster a game...
Give it like 20 years...
Not...
Wait...
Oh god...
How many years?
It must be at least 10...
Until Dawn is like 10, right?
It's not even 10 years...
It came out in 2015...
Oh, it is...
It's 2024...
I still need it...
Give it 20 years...
I feel like...
20 years is like the perfect time for a remaster...
But I also don't think...
Until Dawn needs a remake...
Only because...
Until Dawn...
Is still playable...
Like...
It's still playable...
And like...
It doesn't look like it's aged...
Like...
It looks like Impa still works...
Too...
Like...
It doesn't look like it's like...
Super aged or anything...
Or like the graphics were bad...
It just didn't need a remake...
At best...
It just needed to be ported into a newer system...
Like...
I can understand porting...
Porting until Dawn...
Into newer systems...
But like...
Am I supposed to talk to you?
Like...
I don't understand...
Do you...
Are you lonely?
Like...
Sir...
I'm literally hired help...
Like...
I don't understand...
I'm fucking working...
Like...
If you want me to clean or not...
Did they listed the original?
Are you...
Oh my god...
Bro...
Lord Farquaad is trying to slide into your DMs right now...
Alright...
All I'm saying is that...
He owns a...
Does anyone want to date Lord Farquaad?
He literally owns...
Land...
You can clean whatever...
I am clean!
Look!
I got 41%!
Oh my god...
I don't even think I made much progress...
I don't even...
Holy shit...
I barely fucking progressed...
I wanted to clean Shrek's house!
I'll never get to clean his fucking swamp!
I can't believe the first fucking level is a stupid castle!
Can't believe it...
Less yapping...
More cleaning...
Doki...
Do it for Shrek...
You know what I miss?
I miss Shrek Day...
It was a day for like...
Where people would just celebrate Shrek...
And they took it away from us...
I hope Shrek 5...
Would be good...
I think every Shrek movie has actually been really...
I think it has been decent, every Shrek movie...
Except for one, the one where Shrek has to find the prince...
Nevermind, we don't talk about Shrek 3...
But I think every movie, other than Shrek 3...
Has been...
Yeah, I was thinking about Shrek 3...
I saw that in theaters and I was thinking about it back then...
And I was like, oh yeah...
Nevermind, I already forgot...
How?
Who said Shrek 4 was bad?
Who the fuck?
I cried!
I cried in Shrek 4!
I watched it in the theaters!
And I fucking cried!
Why did I cry in Shrek 4?
Because at one point...
He fucking dies!
And then I was like...
I can't believe they killed Shrek!
And then I cried!
What do you mean?
What the fuck do you mean Shrek 4 is bad?
I've never cried over Shrek before!
And I can't believe they almost actually tried to kill him!
I was so surprised because I was like...
He's in the fucking movie title!
You don't just kill off the fucking guy in the movie title!
And then I fucking cried because they actually tried!
And then he was okay.
And then he was like...
J.K.
It was like...
And then...
And then so...
So I thought it was a...
I thought it was a pretty good movie.
I thought it was a really good movie.
But I hope Shrek 5 is decent.
The funny thing about it...
Oh yeah, I was gonna say it.
Shrek is all about criticizing companies getting greedy with properties and stuff.
And they're criticizing Disney and the way they do things regarding Disney movies.
And then it's so funny because...
Shrek ended up doing the same thing in the end.
Like...
And then Shrek got super popular, the brand.
And then it was like...
They ended up becoming what they were trying to criticize.
Yeah, they literally became the villain.
Bro, it happened so fast.
It literally happened in one fucking movie.
Because nobody expected Shrek to be that popular.
They realized that they too can be capitalist.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Last time I cried watching something was when my tax guy was doing taxes.
Okay, but that's reasonable.
That's reasonable.
Is that and also Shrek dying.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Turtles, thank you for the super chat.
To be fair, you can probably yeet the little guy out the window and inherit it.
It's not like police exist in the air.
I'm literally a cop right now.
Okay, not a knight.
Not a cop.
But like...
That's what knights are for.
That's...
That's literally what knights are for.
They're the ye olde medieval cops.
Yeah, basically a cop.
Ye olde medieval cops.
What a waste of good dragoon eggs.
Guys, we might need to replenish our dragoons.
We've lost many eggs today.
My eggs.
Rest in peace, newbies.
I know, what a good waste of food.
How would a dragoon...
How would the other dragoons eat now?
I guess you guys could lick the eggs off of this.
That would be so much easier.
Wait, is there public lobbies?
Okay.
Wait.
Okay, let me...
No!
It has to be friends only.
That's fucked.
I wanted to see if I could get like an invite code.
And then like...
I wanted to see...
I wanted to see if there was a way to get an invite code.
And then just...
Guys, I just wanted to see if I could outsource my work, okay?
I just wanted to know.
Oh, I can...
Wait, I can skip this?
Oh my god.
This is all I wanted.
Wait, this is the honeymoon.
This is the honeymoon.
I left.
I already left the job.
What are you doing in my...
That's not your swamp, Shrek.
This is where he's gonna get busy.
We could have...
We could have skipped this all along.
We're at Hanzo's honeymoon hideaway.
Wait, what is the green?
Oh no, did he ogre all over it?
Like...
This is...
Oh no, why is it green?
Oh no.
How do I open the door?
Guys, I don't feel comfortable with the fact that...
It's green.
I don't feel...
Guys, it's the honeymoon suite, guys.
It's the honeymoon suite, though.
It's the...
Don't open the door, Doki.
Don't do it!
How do I open the door anyway?
Do I have to clean the inside?
I don't think so.
Oh, thank God.
I gotta make sure.
Chimney, front door, front door, front wall, front window.
Signpost.
Onion carriage.
Okay, it's...
I don't.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Wait, is there...
Is there a way to access the other one?
Okay, we're just gonna clean this first.
Alright, well...
We don't ask questions, guys.
We all signed a contract.
We can't ask any questions as to why...
As to why the...
Why is there green?
No filter is wild!
Alright, you explain why it's green!
Thank you.
Why else would it be green?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Neko, thank you for your very first super chat.
Did you know that the Shrek film is in the U.S.
Library of Congress?
It is a...
It is a part of history.
I'm not surprised.
Generations...
How Shrek is love and Shrek is life.
You know what should be in the Congress?
That...
That video.
That video changes people.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Loli, thank you for the super chat.
Did you read the original Shrek book where he has heat vision?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm pretty sure the original book has nothing to do with any of the movies.
I...
Why is there mold?
Why is there mold on this house?
Like, this is...
Is that black mold?
Like, is that...
Guys.
Guys, I think we need to call somebody.
That's black mold.
There's no...
It's a cat house.
It's made of...
I feel like...
I feel like this house...
Might not be safe to live in.
It's a gingerbread house.
Don't ask questions, Doki.
You signed a contract.
Doki, you're not supposed to ask questions.
Fun, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No wonder Fiona chose to be with Shrek.
If that's what the house looks like, she probably...
I didn't...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No.
I miss...
I miss eating gingerbread.
I haven't had gingerbread in a long time.
Yay.
I just want to clean the swamp.
How many percentages do I have to unlock to get the swamp?
I just want to get to the house.
Okay, maybe if I just do this.
Maybe if I...
Maybe if I get to 30%.
I'll just like clean really fast.
And then maybe I'll get to 30%.
And then I'm gonna...
I'll be able to...
I don't know why you're bothering.
This place looks fine to me.
Oh, Shrek.
You fucking freak.
Shrek.
You are such a goddamn freak, my dude.
You're such a...
Although there might be an odd...
Is that what you call it?
Is that what you and Fiona call it?
I'm snotting.
I'm...
Toki, no!
No, Toki!
It's all over.
He's gonna ogre all over the place.
Toki, why?
Look, look.
If that's what they're into, guys.
If that's what Fiona and Shrek calls it these days.
Then why...
Who are we to judge?
Who are we to judge them and their love life?
Aphelion!
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, he ogred all over here too.
Guys, that's why they had three kids.
That's all I'll say.
See?
Weren't they triplets?
Oh, that's what they want you to believe.
Honestly, like...
It's triplets, but it's not how we think happened.
Alright.
This is like almost clean enough.
Literally, it's just a roof.
Loli, thank you for the super chat.
Can I do his house now?
Can I do his house?
Can I afford it?
Can I afford his house now?
No, I don't wanna do Duloc again.
What the fuck?
How do I unlock the new?
How do I unlock...
Oh, maybe if I hit 46%.
Is it 46%?
Then I unlock it?
Oh, Ozni.
No.
I still can't believe she blew up that much.
It's not funny.
How is that a meme?
Like, good...
Okay, honestly, though.
Good on her for like capitalizing on the...
Capitalizing on everything.
But like, I just don't find it funny.
Like, I...
I respect the grind.
I do respect the grind, though.
Like, good on her for the fucking grind.
I just personally don't find it funny.
At all.
I don't have...
I have no idea.
Cause like, you know.
It's like...
I guess it's like normie humor.
Like, I'm pretty normie.
But like, that is way too normie for me.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since it's a swamp, it will be needed after you clean it.
You get reverse a mechanic.
And you just get some sort of filth gun to re-swampify the place.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's a nice concept.
I actually like that.
Maybe if I clean it at 40%.
Then I would...
Then I'll unlock the swamp.
Medi, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's got his ogre all over the place.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you feel like you became less normie over the years?
Um...
Not really.
Not really, because like...
Um...
I feel like...
Uh...
I...
I like...
I'm like at the gamer category of normie.
So like, I'm not like frat boy normie.
I'm like gamer...
Gamer normie.
So you know like...
You know...
You know what I mean by gamer normies?
Like...
Obviously...
Like, you know, like...
Gamer normies were like...
All they do is play like Call of Duty.
And...
Yeah, the gamer pro normie.
I suppose there might be a slight stain by the...
What did you do?
Shrek...
What the fuck were you and Veniona into?
Like...
I was boiling...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you were boiling up some slime-covered toadstool...
For a late night hot toadie.
And it exploded...
Oh, is that what they call it?
Like, it really caked itself on the wall.
Oh, yeah, it exploded all right.
Toki, please.
Yeah.
And by slime-covered toadstool...
That's what he calls...
That's what he calls me.
Shrek, this is a little TMI.
I'm just a hired help.
Shrek is love.
Shrek is life.
Guys, if I have to get fucking TMI texts from Shrek...
Then you do too.
Then you have to live through this too with me.
Do I...
How do I unlock it?
Is it 46%?
I just don't understand.
I don't understand how I unlock the honeymoon stage.
Like, I feel like I've already cleaned up so much.
These techniques from the Shrekku Sutra sure are something.
Cats, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Isn't this Gingerbread Man?
No, it's Hansel's hat.
Hansel took over.
This is now Hansel's domain now.
Oh, I just wanted to clean the swamp.
Now I'm cleaning his fucking love shack.
Why is it turning into Doki Reads fanfic?
It's not fanfic if Shrek is like fucking texting me this.
I'm literally just trying to clean.
I'm actually trying to do my job.
Okay.
He's the one that's making it inappropriate.
The love shack.
Please give me your swamp to clean.
Please.
To unlock you usually need to get married first.
I just want to unlock his fucking swamp.
That's my endgame.
That's all I want.
Guys, how do I unlock it?
How the fuck do I unlock the fucking swamp?
Is this how Shrek feels when Donkey starts yapping without shutting up?
I mean the dragon likes it.
Okay, but you know like what they say about people.
Okay, I'll stop.
Donkey, stop.
Do I have the swamp unlocked yet?
What do they say?
I don't know.
What do they say, chat?
You guys told me to stop, so I guess I'll stop.
Guess you'll never know.
I guess we'll never know.
Just remember you guys wanted me to stop.
You guys say what?
I don't know.
You guys finally bought my silence, so I guess you'll never know, chat.
I guess we'll never know.
I didn't say stop.
Well, we know who's the freak here, too.
We know who's also a fucking freak, I guess.
Producer didn't want me to stop.
Oh my god.
Am I close to getting- Guys, this is all I wanted.
All I wanted was- I just wanted- Guys, does any- I just wanted- Oh, wait.
I can buy stuff?
I can- Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's $900.
Okay, I can't afford it anyway.
I can't afford it anyway.
I was gonna be like, are you serious?
I could've bought something this entire time, but I couldn't afford it.
Thank fuck you, God.
I was gonna be like- No, my God, I almost did Duloc again.
Please don't make me do Duloc again.
I'm buying your silence.
Go ham, queen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, now we know who's the super freak, too.
Pretty sure we told you to keep going.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Doki is making too many good guesses to be considered innocent, but I can't stop listening.
Thank you for the super chat.
Wings, thank you, thank you.
Cas, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Second and go wild.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Any dragoon who doesn't love- Oh, what does it start saying?
Then there's all that sludge down the side of the house?
Shrek, what?
You took it outside?
We were having a romantic mud bath, and I caught a few fairies in bottles for soft lighting.
Okay, what happened?
You made them watch?
Then to create a full spa experience, I left off a real- You made them watch?
You-
Bro, did the fairies consent to that?
Bro, Shrek.
Guess the smell was too much for the fairies as they all broke free and chased us out the window.
Holy fuck.
Bro, that's fucking freaky, bro.
That's actually- That's actually mega freaky.
Zekra, thank you for the Akasupa, thank you, thank you.
I'm praying you to stop.
Sorry, guys.
My sons got re-bought, guys.
JL, thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, guys, it got re-bought.
Coward.
How dare you?
I'm countering Zekra's Akasupa.
Akasupa, yap away.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you, JL.
Okay, all I'm saying was that- Alright, so you know how, like- I'm praying you to double down.
Thank you for the Akasupa, Anton.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, so I was saying- I don't like how, like- After you clean the black mold off the gingerbread, it's like white underneath.
How do you make such a mess?
Ah, good question.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But like- But like, okay, so like- You know how, like- You know how, like, you know- The dragon and the donkey got together and made three children as well?
So like, I'm just thinking, like- Obviously- Obviously, donkey is a big talk.
Talker, right?
So like-
So like, you know- He knows how to-
Yeah, stop.
He knows how to what, donkey?
I guess he'll never know.
I guess.
Please.
Alright.
Oh my god, is this it?
Is this good enough to unlock the swamp?
How is this not good enough for the swamp?
I don't understand!
I've cleaned 67% of the fucking area!
Yeah!
He just has bard level of riz.
I mean, he could be good at other things.
Now, no need to brag.
We all know- Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just want the swamp.
That's all I want.
That's all I want, Shrek.
How much more do you want me to clean?
I just- Just give me the fucking swamp!
That's my end goal!
That's all I want in life!
Okay.
He doesn't even care that it's dirty!
That's his entire thing!
Okay, this is not my fault.
Pickle cucumber.
I'm literally in the honeymoon suite.
Like, this is not my- Like, they're literally handing me this on a platter.
Like, literally honeymoon time.
Just married.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
Like, they handed it to me on a fucking silver platter.
What am I supposed to do?
I'm not supposed to take it and run with it?
Like- I'm not supposed to take it and run with it?
Oh my god.
Did I unlock it?
No!
I just- I just want- I just want to clean the swamp!
That's all I want!
How do I unlock it?
I'll never unlock the swamp!
I literally cleaned 73% of this area!
It is real!
I saw it in the trailer!
I just wanna- I just wanna go.
Somebody once told me the world.
Give me the swamp.
I'll take things.
Why do I want to clean strex's fiona for $500?
Thank you for the superchat Poppa!
Thank you, thank you!
Duck, thank you for the superchat!
Why do I want to clean strex's swamp so bad?
Shouldn't use a razor for that instead of a power watcher.
Thank you for the superchat, Duck.
Thank you, thank you.
This was all for the swamp.
I literally wanted to do the DLC for the swamp.
And I'm out here fucking cleaning up Shrek's love shack instead.
Like what the fuck is my life now?
Cleaning his goddamn
Goddamn Goddamn Goddamn Fucking snot Quote on quote
This is like You're the janitor at the special movie Movies that are filmed This is how I feel right now I feel like I feel like that janitor
Cleaning the gooning shack
Somebody has to be a janitor for that Like what the Somebody has to clean that
Sir, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And thank you for the super chat.
Think of the swap as a boss.
You need to level up first.
I'm at 80%!
What more do
you - Oh my god.
Please.
Oh, there was a ladder this entire time?!
Oh my god, I need to pick one struggle.
Like-
How many struggles am I gonna pick?
How many struggles?
I'm struggling so much.
I'm struggling so fucking much right now.
I give up.
I can't.
I can't keep doing- Wait, no.
No, Doki.
Never give up.
Never.
Never give up, Doki.
Do it for the swap!
You don't even have to clean the swap.
You just have to look at it, Doki.
Just think about being able to look at that swap!
Just think about it.
Just think about being able to look at it.
That's all.
That's the end goal.
Thanks you.
They'll be able to snot again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Just think about the swap, Doki.
Close your eyes and think about the swap.
All that trauma.
All that trauma for $60.
But just think about the swap.
Push Gaming, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
One cannot simply enter the swap.
One must prove their allegiance and loyalty to the green beast.
Oh my god, please.
What else do I have to clean?
What is there?
I'm literally at 81%.
Don't make me do 100%.
Please don't make me do 100%.
I beg of you.
I cannot do this to myself.
You make me do 100% of this house.
Alright.
Just gonna make sure we get the candy in.
Alright, the candy is all done.
Why are these stains so difficult?
Like, I don't understand.
How could these stains be like this?
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Screw it, I'll ask.
If Fiona's curse never breaks, how would their kids look like?
Do they turn half ogre during the night?
I feel like...
I mean, there's different types of curses.
There's generational curses.
I feel like they'd just be like half ogre, half human hybrids.
Because the ogre is not her...
Okay, I think it depends on which form she is in when she gives birth.
So like, if she's in human form, I guess like the babies will turn human?
And then when she's in ogre form, then the babies...
Or like, it'd be like half...
Or it's... I feel like it could be half ogre, half human hybrids.
Which would make them like mega freaks too.
I mean, we got half dragon, half donkey hybrids, so like...
So like, it's...
There's no like...
It could... Okay!
Also!
Fiona's dad is a fucking frog.
And like, she's not a frog.
So like, I feel like...
They're not... She's not like a half frog, half human.
There's that too.
I'm at 84%... Is it time?
Do I...
Do I get the...
New...
Please...
Trick...
Please don't do this to me...
Trick, please...
Trick...
One last push...
Doki, you're so close...
Doki, one last push...
Wait...
What's the saying called?
Keiji, wait, he's stuck in...
The last job...
lol 95% of gamblers...
lol Gave up...
Before they hit it big...
The Weiji cage...
Dad's Weiji...
Dad...
Oh my god...
Please...
Weiji, Weiji, stuck in your cage all day long, you sweat and rage...
This is my life now...
Cleaning Shrek's...
Love shack...
Honestly, my actual job was like...
My actual job was to be a janitor...
To clean up...
Clean up some of Shrek's, you know, fun times...
Fun freaky times...
I think I'd be very depressed...
lol I think I'd definitely be very disassociated in life...
Oh my god, I went to janitor school for this...
I'm at 85%, guys...
One more, oh my god...
The only way I could get through my job...
My parents would be so proud of me...
There's janitor school...
Of course there is, have you guys not watched Community?
lol How else would they learn the janitor things?
Okay...
I gotta clean up the honeymoon sign...
So people know...
People know what the fuck that shack is for...
Like, why does it have to be 100%?
Why can't it be like 99%?
Oh, it's at 86%!
It's at 86%!
86%!
Jonathan, is this why Airbnbs are so...
Oh, absolutely...
lol
Absolutely...
lol Like, don't think about it...
Like, Jonathan, thank you for the superchat...
lol
Don't think about it too hard, guys...
lol That is why...
That is why I will never do Air...
Okay, to be fair, like, it's the same as hotels...
But like, I trust hotel cleaning more than air...
More than random Airbnb cleaners...
Like, I... fucking...
I don't know, I feel like...
I don't know...
I don't... I feel like people who clean Airbnbs...
Do not get it as...
Do not...
Do not work at it as hard as, like, a hotel cleaner...
I... lol lol The hotel people have a system...
I don't know about Airbnbs...
lol lol
Alright...
I didn't do the wheels...
Why don't they...
It's a car!
Nobody cleans the wheels of a car!
Fucking go to a car wash!
Go to a goddamn car wash at that point!
I'm not... I'm literally here to clean houses!
Like, I'm...
I'm literally here to clean houses!
I'm not a car washer!
Like... lol
Alright...
I'll go...
Back at it again...
Yeah... lol Yeah... lol She's losing it... lol Everything...
The things I do for the swamp...
What the fuck?
You got this part dirty too?
Oh my god...
Here we go...
I'm gonna... lol I'm gonna... lol I'm gonna find where Shrek lives...
Maybe that's why they won't give me the swamp... lol Maybe that's why they don't give me the swamp, guys... lol Maybe that's why...
lol I wanna find where he lives now...
Okay...
Yeah, I know about sea, I just refuse to use it...
We're gonna clean that...
Is this all clean now?
Did I do it?
Oh my god...
There's like the tiniest stains...
How would they know?
Talk, Shrek, right now!
Okay...
We're gonna clean this part...
Right here...
Oh my god...
Please...
I must suffer...
I must suffer for the swamp...
I must...
I swear if we hit 100% and we still...
I swear to god...
I swear to fucking god...
If we hit 100% and we still don't get the swamp...
I...
I swear...
Guys, I need to know...
I need to know, guys...
Do I get the swamp if I finish this job?
I need to know, chat...
Please, this is like all I want to know...
Do I...
Please...
Please don't make me do this all...
Don't tell her...
I just need to know...
Doki, the game came out today...
How the fuck were we supposed to know?
I don't know!
I just...
I need something!
I need a reassurance!
Get the devs right now in my chat!
No, don't get the devs...
Don't get the devs...
Someone ping the chat right now!
Someone ping the devs right now on discord!
They must be in the server somewhere.
She wants to talk to the manager.
Oh my god...
This is hell...
It's all like, small stains of hell right now.
Literally all these small stains have added up to...
have added up to nine... the hundred percent.
I'm actually like, in Dante's Infernal right now.
Like, I...
This is the worst part.
I can't believe... I thought that like, you know, oh, maybe it has to be like the general amount.
Maybe it's like the general amount, and then like, if I could, I would pay to win.
If I could, I would pay like, if they made me pay a hundred dollars to unlock the swamp, I would do it.
I'll pay fucking a hundred real dollar runies just to unlock the swamp.
Anyway...
I thought that like, if I clean a general amount, I would...
I would get the...
I would... I would get it.
So I just half-assed it.
I just cleaned... just to clean to hit forty percent.
Cause that's how we got the honeymoon!
We literally... we literally cleaned forty percent!
And it got the honeymoon!
So I don't understand!
I don't understand!
I did all that and only hit ninety-two percent.
I didn't... I... oh... I...
Oh, she's...
Like, I barely went up.
It barely went up in the fucking clean-o-meter.
Like, I don't understand.
Why did it barely go up?
I... I'm still stuck in that little gap.
That little fucking gap hole of ninety-two percent.
She's losing it, chat.
We're losing it.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god, the moment I find where you live, Shrek.
The moment I fucking find your swamp.
It's so over.
It's so fucking over.
It's so...
I NEED A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY PERCENT?!
Oh my god.
I don't know if I can do that.
We barely hit ninety-three-hundred.
I don't know.
I don't know if we can...
I don't know if that's something we can do.
We gotta...
Guys, this is...
We gotta go to the other map, guys.
It's the only way.
See, it's literally the only way.
We had it.
We got it.
Guys, we just need forty percent.
We just...
Guys.
Guys, we just need forty percent.
We can do it.
We can...
We can do it, I believe.
It's just forty percent.
What?
No, don't tell me I got one, god.
Guys, please.
Please, it's just...
There's no way.
We're so close.
Okay, we can do this.
We can hit that...
The sweet-o spot.
We'll just keep going.
We'll keep going.
This has to be...
This will be like...
This will be the fastest...
Seventy percent of our lives.
We just need to hit eighty.
We just need to hit eighty, guys.
We're already at eighty percent.
We're already at fifty.
We just...
There's no way.
Okay, that guy...
Okay, who said that?
Okay, mods.
Who said a hundred and seventy percent?
Okay, okay.
You.
Okay, I wrote this down so I remember.
If it's not...
I swear to God.
Alright, this is the size of your fate.
All I'm saying...
Is that bad button looks really fucking pretty right now.
It's on...
All I'm saying...
Is that that bad button...
Oh, if I hit that eighty percent...
I'm not playing.
I'm not playing right now.
Okay.
We're new fast, so like...
We're gonna hit that.
She's going crazy with power.
Okay, wait, give me a sec.
Let me...
Let me find that message again.
Oh, you're so lucky.
You are so lucky.
I can't find...
I can't find that message again.
But like...
I was gonna put you up there on the screen.
As like a countdown.
It's like...
I was gonna give a little countdown on what it will be like if it's not true.
Oh my god.
This is...
This is gonna take...
There's no way.
Like how long is this gonna take me?
There's no fucking way.
Almost.
You're almost fifty.
You're almost there!
Okay, I'm fucking...
We're bringing in the big boys for this.
It might not be the cleanest.
But like the range is higher and that's all that matters for me.
That's all that matters.
Oh, you're awfully quiet, Ikemia.
You're...
Oh, you're awfully quiet.
You're fucking sweating.
You're...
You seem awfully quiet right now in my fucking chat.
I don't see you talking no more.
They ran.
The silence is deafening.
Okay.
I guess...
I know it's not very pretty right now, but I'm trying to do it as fastly as I can.
Try getting the first area to 50% or I have...
Don't worry, I have it.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You never came back.
We don't think you're safe.
Fucking...
I don't know if you know this, Ikemia.
But like you can look back into the VODs and then you can timestamp for timestamp where he says 170%.
And then you can look back and look at chat replay.
And then you can ban them from chat replay.
That's all I...
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA You think you can get away just cause you haven't chatted now?
You think you can get away cause I haven't chatted now?
All I'm saying is that I can do chat replay.
She's got her plan.
I have my plan right now.
If it's not 170...
Oh, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm locked in.
There's always a record.
Guys this was not supposed to be three hours of power wash simulator.
I literally have another stream in two hours guys, but like I need to unlock the swap.
I need to- don't understand.
I need to unlock the swap.
This was my entire reason for being here.
I'm literally playing the game for the fucking- I made the somebody joke two times on social media!
And I- it would be so embarrassing if I don't get the swap after I made that joke two times on social media.
Like, it's all I have.
It's-
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Completing individuals up to ding makes your perfect percent raise faster and will save your insanity.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is what I needed.
Don't worry, I'll complete the flower pot.
Why is the flower pot not dinging?
Why is the- why is the fucking window not- oh there we go.
There we go, 53%.
Okay, we got the flower.
Oh my god, what is the easiest for the ding?
Thank you for your very fifth- your fifth super chat, man.
Thank you, thank you.
She went- skipped the other parts of grief and went straight for the hit.
Okay.
Okay, we got the window.
We're at 54.
Oh my god.
Okay, I can't.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
We gotta at least clean this door.
It went ding, but why?
It went ding, but why is it still 54?
I don't understand!
I was told!
I was told it would go
- I've been lied to.
It's still at 54.
Toki, it's a city and you clean one door.
But they said- they said the ding!
The ding will make it go faster!
Poor Toki can't even unlock the s- Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Who are these people?
I hope they've all been executed!
Oh my god, Toki can't just say that.
Guys, it's ye olde medieval times!
It was the norm!
That's what they do in the ye olde medieval times!
Okay, here we go.
Toki's becoming Lord Farquaad.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, I just- I don't know, I don't know.
I don't know how much longer- I thought that getting to 80% would be like so easy, but it's not.
It's not.
Doing this was easier than the dings!
Holy shit, actually doing that was- doing that actually made more progress.
Where's my giant ladder?
Where the fuck is my giant ladder?
Okay.
Okay, we're just gonna clean as much as we can to make it to-
To make it- we just need 80%.
We literally- we literally just need 80%.
What do you mean you didn't lie?
You guys told me to just clean individual spots until you hear the ding!
But me just doing this made it go faster!
I already am at 57%!
I'm literally at 57% because I'm just- I'm just going- rolling in with the times!
Oh my god, and then we'll clean this like this.
We'll just be like, it's alright clean.
It's alright clean.
It's clean enough.
Oh my god, please.
I can't even hit 60%.
I can't- I can't- Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're like 20- we're almost 20%.
I'm actually at- I don't even know where did I started.
What was my percentage before going in?
Like, did I even made any progress?
Oh my god.
Did I- did I even made- I made 10% progress?
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but like, Power Wash Simulator is supposed to be a relaxing game.
Guys, and I def- I don't know about you guys, but like, is this the feeling of relaxation?
Is- Is this- is this what relaxation is supposed to feel?
I suppose you'd be wondering why I didn't go and rescue my betrothed personally.
Farquhar, please.
Please, I would- You send me another text message, I'll go up to the castle myself and fucking throw you off the castle.
I- and then I'll clean the mess up because I learned in Crime Scene Killer- Crime Scene Cleaner how to hide- how to hide a crime.
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where did it end?
Where did it begin?
I don't even know the washing and stains.
The washing and the stains, the face, blue eyes, face, blue eyes.
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All I'm saying, that in order to have- in order for Crime Scene Cleaner to happen, somebody had to be killed.
What?
Sorry, oh my god, it's so unfortunate that there was an- there was an accident with Lord Farquhar where he just happened to just fall off the building.
That- oh, that's so fucking crazy.
That's- well, thoughts and prayers.
Soma, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What a nice, relaxing game.
The what-if scenario.
Oh my god, 61%.
Guys, this already looks so clean.
Okay.
I'll clean this.
And then...
It's just a little more.
We're at 62%.
We're so close to the percent.
We just- the moment I see that 70%, I'll know my goal.
I'll know my goal the moment I see that 70%.
Then I know what I fought for.
Do it for the swamp!
Do it for Team Fortress 2 Scout!
Was it Scout?
Or was it Heavy?
I don't remember.
No, it wasn't.
It was Nick from Left 4 Dead 2.
Do it for Nick from Left 4 Dead 2.
That's it.
It was Ellis.
Oh my god.
Do it for Ellis.
Sorry, I got Nick and Ellis confused.
It was Ellis.
Do it for him.
Just remember what he did for us.
Wait, what do I- Does this get rid of the-okay, it does.
It gets rid of the cock.
Get your head out of the gutter, guys.
That's what roosters are called.
I think that's-oh, that's why it's a rooster!
Wait, that's so clever!
It's supposed to do a triad!
That's actually-okay, not gonna lie.
That's actually so clever that they, like...
That they drew, like, a rooster to symbolize, like...
To symbolize the peepee graffiti.
That's so clever.
Oh yeah!
I think-wait, has it been announced?
Oh yeah, so there's gonna be a-by the way, it's been announced, but...
There's gonna be a new-that's a sponsored tournament I'm doing on Sunday.
It's a Stranova tournament, so I got sponsored to be part of it.
They paid a lot.
So I was like, okay.
Cool.
I dragged Surefour in.
So, like...
That's the only person I know that's in my team.
Because they were like, oh!
You can bring, like, another content creator to also get sponsored.
So then I was like, alright, Surefour, you wanna join?
And he's like, yeah, sure.
So and then they're like, oh yeah, and then the other teams is just like...
Basically, the other teammates are just like people who bring, like, people assigned to my team.
Because, like, technically I'm the captain of the team.
Technically I'm, like, the captain of the team, so, like, but, like, I-fucking, I was like, I don't know, I was like, fucking, I don't know.
I was like...
I was like, I mean, sweet.
Last time I played, I did it for free, now I got paid for it, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
I mean...
My favorite capitalistic, oh shit.
Look, I don't have the, guys, look, I don't have the MrBeast money, guys.
I take what I can get.
And MrBeast comes up to me and was like, oh yeah, you wanna join this thing for $500,000?
You know you're fucking, you bet your ass I'd say yes.
Just like all of you guys would too.
Don't lie, you guys would have done the same thing.
I would not!
I'm gonna sign you up for a MrBeast thing right now, and you're gonna try and prove, and I wanna see you prove my point.
I'm gonna fucking message MrBeast and be like, hey, can you send this person an, I'm gonna create a fake MrBeast account, and then like, send you a DM.
And...
I'm gonna make a fake MrBeast account, send you a YouTube channel DM, and be like, hey, you wanna join, right?
Just to see if you would say yes or no.
And I'll make it so fucking real that you wouldn't know, that you wouldn't know.
And now you're gonna be so paranoid, cause you're like, what if you actually rejected a real MrBeast invite?
Oh no, she's scheming.
Oh my god, we're at 67.
How much do I need, chat?
How much?
Not the beast maxing.
78.
We're so, we're almost there.
We're almost at the 70 mark, guys.
The liar bar has changed.
Power washing has changed me.
And all it took was one day.
One bad day.
That's all it takes, guys.
One bad day at power washing.
Oh my god, you know what's funny?
Speaking of Joker, apparently it's almost equivalent, Joker 2 earnings is almost equivalent to Morbius.
Which is saying a lot.
Because at least Morbius, you have the memes.
But like, what do we have in Joker 2?
To be fair, I never watched the first Joker movie.
Because like, I normally never watch depressing movies.
So like, I tend to avoid these types of movies.
So like, I, in my opinion, I just don't care.
Like, in my opinion.
Oh yeah, and apparently the reason why it's so bad is because the director has like, the director has literally no control over the movie this time around.
So that's why it's so fucking bad.
The director literally had no control on what to do with the movie for the second movie.
So it was mostly controlled by the guy who played Joker.
And also the board.
How is that possible?
That's basically all superhero movies.
So there's gonna be like a parody show.
I don't know if you guys saw the trailer for it.
Um...
And like...
Uh...
Oh yeah, what's the exact opposite?
I thought I heard that he...
The director had full control?
Didn't they say...
Uh...
It's not the opposite?
Oh shit, I thought he didn't have any control.
I thought, like, there was like...
Um...
There were like...
Uh...
I don't know, it's like all over the place.
I saw it was the director and...
Oh, it's the director and the lead actor.
I thought it was like...
There was like a source that said like...
Uh...
Oh, the director is different!
Oh, okay.
I thought it was the same director.
It had a lot of control.
Everything that happened was signed for by him.
Cause I was thinking about like...
Cause I saw like...
Uh...
Saw them saying that...
The actor was saying how like...
Don't blame it on the director.
Because like...
Um...
It wasn't his fault.
So I thought, like...
Maybe that's a lie.
Cause I saw him mentioning that.
Cause he was saying like...
Oh, don't blame it.
Don't blame it.
Look, I didn't even watch the first Joker.
And I'm definitely not gonna watch the second Joker.
Cause they were saying like...
Oh yeah, don't blame it on him.
Because like...
Um...
Uh...
He...
It wasn't his fault.
The movie was really bad.
Oh, I know about bad!
They did zero test screening by the way.
I know about that too.
They did zero test screening for the second movie for some reason.
Now I know that's not misinformation.
Cause I read about that as well.
Which is crazy to say.
Because the Wally Coyote vs.
Acne movie had several test screenings.
And it tested really well.
So like...
And then they shelved that movie.
I think the CEO of Warner Brothers is just a really bad CEO.
Like he saves money for the company, but he has terrible movie decisions.
Yeah, the CEO is just really, really bad when it comes to decisions about movies.
But he's really good at saving money.
For some fucking reason.
XD
But, I think...
I think the CEO is just not really good with movie decisions.
I fucking hate him because he shelved the Wally Coyote movie.
Cause that movie actually looks really decent.
I really was looking forward to watching that too.
What was I going to say?
There was something I wanted to say about the Joker movie.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
So there's going to be a TV show that's coming out.
That basically uses real life accounts from superhero productions.
There's this new British TV show that's coming out that's like a mockumentary.
And they're basically making fun of superhero movies.
And basically, one of the things that was actually apparently a true story.
Was that they don't reveal which superhero movies they got the sources from.
And one of the things they got that they made a parody over.
Was that...
I don't know...
Obviously we don't know if it's Marvel or DC.
But one of them, it's either Marvel or DC.
Made a director film fake scenes.
Because they didn't want to tell the director that they didn't like what he's doing.
So they made the director film fake scenes.
And then have the real scenes filmed at a different location.
And they didn't tell him.
So they just made him...
They just made him...
They just made him film that without...
And be like, sorry, we're not even going to use them.
But we just wanted you as a director.
And I'm like...
I'm like, that's absolutely crazy.
Like, what's the point?
What?
Why do that?
Like, if you don't like the scene...
Just tell him.
Like, at that point, he's not even directing anymore.
He's just the face.
This is like giving your fucking sibling the fake controller.
Like, also, that's such a huge waste of money.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
Oh my god, it's the 78%.
We're almost there, guys.
It's literally 1%, guys.
Oh my god, we're at the 1%.
Oh, we're at the final point!
This is it!
Oh, there's a roof.
I'm going to clean as much as I can.
Oh my god, it's literally the 1% right here.
I'm trying to clean as much as random shit I can everywhere.
Like, this random shit is going to add up to the 1% right here.
Look at the stuff I didn't clean.
But don't worry.
That's what...
Okay!
Alright, here it is!
78%!
78%, guys.
70...
I swear to god.
At this together...
At this together, are we at 107...
At this...
At this together...
At...
raine.gif
At this together...
Where is it?
Oh, it's 79 just to be safe?
Okay!
79 to be safe?
Okay, guys, it's 79 to be safe.
Oh, let's add that in.
All right.
Okay, 79 just to be safe.
Must be a glitch, right?
Must be a fucking glitch.
All right, if you say so.
Oh, it's just all just a silly glitch.
All right, let's oh, let's get that 79% in there.
Oh, what about 80?
Oh, okay.
Oh, all right.
Let's get that 80 in here.
Let's get that.
Oh, oh, you're right.
Maybe if I round it to 80.
Oh, maybe...
If I round it to 80.
Okay.
All right.
That's...
Okay, if that's what you say.
Oh, if that is what you say.
Oh, and we're almost to 80, guys.
We're almost to 80, guys.
We're almost there.
Check his mood.
Oh, check his bathroom.
Before you do anything in the swamp.
Okay, let's hope we get there first.
Like...
Guys, first off, we gotta make sure we fucking even get there, guys.
We gotta make sure we even live to tell the tale.
Okay.
What am I cleaning at this point?
Like, where is the window?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
I'll clean this.
Maybe the real swamp were the friends we made a long... don't give me that pussy-ass shit right now.
I've been here for three hours.
No, no friends were made right now.
In fact, we lost friends.
We lost friends.
One person is about to get fucking bad.
Lord Farquaad, I swear to god.
People are underestimating how difficult it is to be one of the most difficult.
All right.
This is it.
This is fucking it.
All right, we'll let Lord Farquaad say his truth real fast.
For example, every day I must deprive hard-working citizens the pleasure of life's pleasure.
Yeah, my fucking swamp.
That is a ruler.
The dull, uneventful existence is a burden that I alone must carry.
I swear.
I swear to fuck you.
Okay, here we go.
Here we fuck you go.
This is it.
We'll look at his face while we do this.
All I'm saying...
All right, I'll pray for you.
Man is indiscretion.
Thomas, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, Mia.
Don't.
Even if you run away now, just know I can find you.
So take this.
So reveal yourself right now.
For the sake of everybody, reveal yourself right now.
So at least you can die with some dignity.
So I heard it unlocks at 180 wings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for give the father for they not know what they did.
Okay, Mia, I'm gonna...
Okay, Mia, this is your one chance to at least take it with some form of dignity.
Oh, I need one level at a hundred percent.
Okay, who said that?
Okay.
All right.
Are you... how?
How?
Are you really... are you... are you gonna join Alchemia?
Are you...
Are you here to join Alchemia with that statement?
This is your chance to back out.
I will... I'll give you the... I'll... I have, you know, I have like some...
Some...
I will... I will give you some form of pity.
Do you agree with that statement?
Do you... do you...
Do you want to say that statement again to me in my chat?
Oh, you're not even...
Eevee, I'm just gonna say.
Are you...
I have some... I... I still have mercy in me.
Do you... are you willing to...
Are you willing...
to say that again, Eevee?
Are you... are you a fucking coward?
I feel a little merciful right now.
Are you... are you willing to say that statement again, Eevee?
Say it again!
Come on!
Pick up the sword again.
Pick it up.
They ran away.
Well...
It looks like Eevee decided not to say it again.
Oh, I believe!
Oh, oh!
Oh!
All right, all right, all right.
Okay.
Wow, that... that is some fucking confidence right there.
All right, here we go.
That is some absolute confidence right there.
Okay, he fucking believes with his fucking heart right now.
He has...
Guys, I have... I have an hour and 30 minutes to see the swap.
That's all that matters.
I have an hour.
Akumia has been saved for like an extra 30 minutes.
They gets to live another extra 30 minutes because of Eevee.
Yeah!
Oh my god, what the fuck is this green- pink stuff?
Who else was part of this party?
Okay, we gotta...
We gotta change the extendo.
Oh my god.
This is how Toki's villain arc begins.
All right, let's clean them.
Let's clean whatever the fuck this is.
Wait.
No, oh my god.
I got an achievement.
I thought I got baited.
I got an achievement and I thought...
I thought it was over.
I legitimately felt happiness for five seconds.
I...
I felt five seconds of pure happiness because I thought that was it.
Oh my god, how am I gonna... oh my god, please.
How is there still stains?
Okay, we got the... okay, we gotta get the door.
It has to be outside at this point.
Okay.
Oh my god, what else am I missing in this stupid carriage?
What am I supposed to...
Okay,
it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything, if a janitor can do this every day, so can I.
Okay, we got the interior.
We got the seating.
We got the... the... the fucking... oh my god, I can't even get out.
I can't even...
I can't even get out.
Okay, we got... grab the outside.
Okay, we got that.
Now we gotta get the onion skin.
Alright, how long of a banner are we gonna sign up for if we lie on the... forever.
Oh, you think... you think this is like a slap on the wrist?
I play power wash similar for three hours.
I play...
Oh, you think... you think lying on the internet is... oh, you think there's no consequences to lying on the internet?
You really...
You really think there's no consequences when it comes to lying on the...
I don't know.
Okay.
Alright, this...
You're gonna learn.
You're gonna learn your fu... your... your consequences when it comes to lying.
Better make a new account if you want to come back.
Alright, we got the carriage wheel.
We got this.
What the fuck am I missing from the onion carriage skin?
Assume like the doors is like... is the doors part of it?
No, it is.
Oh my god.
That gets IP bad.
Oh my god, that door is so dirty.
It's so fucking dirty.
Holy shit.
There has to be an easier way!
Can't believe it.
So much.
Oh my god, even the music stopped.
Even the music was like, please, please be done with this.
We've been here for so long, Doki.
Like, I...
Oh.
Alright.
Okay, we got the stupid-ass luggage roll.
Now we gotta get the flat bed and then the fucking... is the chest clean?
How?
Okay.
Is this the underside of the flat bed?
Oh my god, it is.
Where else is it?
Okay, the tiny little stains here.
Where else have I not cleaned it?
Oh, thank god.
Please.
Where else?
What am I missing?
What am I fucking missing on the onion skin?
Oh, there it is.
I did it.
Okay, there.
It's done.
And then the carriage wheel.
Alright.
There's still five more percent.
I know.
Oh, you know what I know?
That Eevee guy will think, like, she's not gonna make it.
She's not gonna make it to 100% before her next collab.
But I'm so fucking locked in right now, Eevee.
I'll have you know, I am so fucking locked in right now.
I just- oh, you're gonna regret saying I believe.
You're gonna regret it.
I still have an hour and 20 minutes to make that 100%.
Oh, you think- you think you can- you think just because, like, the collab is in an hour and- Oh, you think because the collab is in an hour and 20 minutes that I will not complete this in time?
Oh, shoot.
You think that was gonna make you safe, Eevee?
Oh, at least Akimia has the dignity to fucking leave because she knows she was wrong.
At least Akimia knew before she embarrassed herself even more.
She fucking-
Honjord, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
I love how Doki was always powered by spite.
Oh my god, you grabbed every single part of this goddamn icing.
Me remembering Doki is supposed to have a chest bump, but the artist forgot to make one.
There's one consequence.
Thank god for life.
How how am I supposed to- HOW?
HOW?
MY LADDER'S NOT EVEN TALL ENOUGH!
Here we go It's just 1% Literally just that one.
Okay.
Oh another piece done.
Another piece is done.
Oh, it's getting closer.
It is getting awfully close now, Eevee!
It's getting so goddamn close.
Oh another piece is done.
Another piece is done.
Oh That is so close.
That frost icing right there.
Okay, let's get that canopy, too.
I'm gonna make sure this is the cleanest fucking shit you've ever seen.
I'm gonna make sure.
Okay, we need- we need the ladder.
We need the fucking ladder.
Oh my god, look at- look at this work of art that I'm doing.
96, you're 4% away.
You are 4% away.
I'm just saying, this is 4% closer.
Where's the window frame?
What do I need to clean up?
What do I need to clean left?
Oh, this part.
All right, what else?
All right, all the edges.
Every single one of these edges.
I am afraid.
Oh you- oh you better be.
You better- you know how those other streamers will have like unbanned requests?
We will never have an unbanned.
There is no such thing in Doki's world.
I will literally delete you out of existence.
All right, let's see.
Doki is unforgi- There's no forgiveness here.
You know what you did.
Okay, oh we're getting closer.
Oh, we're getting us so much closer.
He- he knew the risk.
Gotta make sure I got all of these.
What am I missing in the- oh there, the edge here.
Okay, the roof icing.
It's like the corners here.
Oh, that's a lot.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, we still have like- oh there it is.
I was like wondering what I'm missing from that icing area.
Oh my god.
There's so many- oh more.
93% I hope you got a priest to fucking- It's like death's row right now.
Like I hope you had your final meal and- And you- and you got the priest over to say your rites.
Everything.
Their final message before it- Okay, oh it has to be at the bottom here.
Oh, three more percent left.
Three more percent left.
Oh, it's on up to the top.
Okay.
Okay, it's the icing.
Oh, the side windows.
I don't know what to do here.
All right.
Is there anything else that's not seen?
The consumer music is not helping the vibe.
This is like- this is the theme of the- this is- this might as well be the theme of the stream.
Oh my god, the amount of fucking progress I have made here today.
I am not a coward, dude.
Thank you for the super chat, Warren.
Thank you.
Oh, so fun.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
How am I missing on the wall?
Might as well clean the gumdrop too.
I'm like missing something from this wall, but I feel like this wall is like so fucking clean right now.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, the stairs.
Okay, it has to be this part of the stairs.
Come on.
Oh, the underside.
It's always the underside.
Yeah, holy shit, the underside.
Oh my god.
We're at 2%.
I hope you talked to your priest and got your final meal.
It's at 2%.
This is it.
The final- the final frontier.
You thought- you thought I would not- you thought like, oh, Jokey has a collab in like, in an hour.
There's no way she would need like a little bit of time to- of intermission before she goes to- Oh, you think I'm- oh, you think I won't fucking delay a collab just to prove a point?
You think- You think I will stop even when the collab hits?
Oh, you think-
I would absolutely delay a collab if it means I gotta prove that I'm right.
Oh,
you thought you were safe?
You thought you were safe?
Then we'll fucking do this all the way to the goddamn end.
She's stunning.
Okay, it's the side wall.
This would be like, down here or something.
Oh, it's over here.
There we go.
I fucking knew it.
Side window?
Where the fuck is the dirty on the side window?
Oh, here.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, I just have to be on top of this now.
Wait, unless roof, icing, roof...
Okay, I need to make sure.
Yeah, I'm- I'm not- Can't fool me.
I know it's not- I know they're not gonna be like, um, actually, it's actually you need the tower- the castle.
No, you don't- you don't fool me.
You don't fucking fool me.
My
god, okay.
Okay, we got- What do we not do?
What do we not do?
What do we not do from here?
The railing?
But where in the rail- oh, is it the underside of- oh my god.
Oh my god.
I didn't even realize there was more to this.
It was the underside of the railing.
Okay.
Two more.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, that's done.
That part's done.
That is all done.
Okay, now it's time for the roof.
Oh, it's- Okay, we're at this point in our lives.
The 1% left.
This guy's either gonna be fucking saved from execution or he's gonna- we're bringing back- We're bringing- or we're bringing it fucking back.
Or it's coming back right now.
There's a roof- where?
Oh, there's the dirty spot.
Okay.
Just trying to figure out what other part is dirty.
There's the other- oh nice.
Okay, and then the roof icing.
Chat reflects the stream.
Boyo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, oh, that's a huge spot right here.
Where are the others on the ice?
Oh, there.
Okay, I was gonna say, like, I got everything.
Oh,
that is really dirty.
Oh my god, it's so- we almost got everything from this roof.
Nice.
Okay, what else?
Roof icing, chimney.
I think the chimney is the last part.
Oh wait, no, this part of the roof icing.
Oh my god, how much from the roof is fucked up?
There's, like, more on the roof?
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, I found it.
I was like, what the fuck?
What am I missing?
I was so confused.
I was like, what am I missing from the roof?
From the icing?
Okay, nice, this part is done.
Oh, this is it.
This is it.
More people want to know if we're gonna witness a live execution of Eevee and-
This is the final frontier.
Okay, I need- I need the longer muzzle.
Oh, come on.
How the fuck am I supposed to get that donut?
Okay, guys, it's okay.
I'm calm.
She said calmly.
Like- Whoa!
Okay, we got this chimney.
Now, we gotta do the chimney donut.
Okay, one chimney donut.
Why is this donut still, like, dirty?
Okay, last chimney donut.
This might be the last chimney donut.
Wait, I can move this?
I can- Whoa!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Front door handle, onion, roof, icing.
Where?
Which roof?
Oh my god, it's this roof.
Okay, onion care step.
This is your final time.
Oh, front door handle.
Oh, oh that new job.
This is it.
This is- This is me.
This is me.
This is- We don't know yet.
We don't know yet.
Oh.
You live another day.
You live another day, Eevee.
The fact that Eevee stuck his neck out for- for another dragoon.
He actually stuck his head- neck out for the other dragoon.
For Alchemia, he was like, I got you.
So they can put the super chat naked naked.
He didn't even know this person and he was willing to do it all for them.
Their entire- He was willing to bet their- his entire account for this guy- for this random dragoon.
We were all- we were all gathered around the- the chair being like, getting the popcorn ready.
But he was saved.
The final- all right.
We gotta go to the- Open the door.
I did it.
What happens if I- What's the easter egg?
Is there an easter egg?
What's the easter egg?
He has lied to me!
You guys said- you guys said there was an easter egg!
Okay.
Some - Somebody once told me but- oh, I have to clean it?
Oh, I have to clean it.
Okay.
Who said that?
Okay, okay.
Okay,
I need- Okay, all right.
All right, all right, here we go.
Here we go.
Somebody will take the chair today!
Somebody- we all gathered around the chair.
We- we all gathered around.
Somebody is going out today.
I told you that.
We all gathered around for a show.
Here we go again.
Okay, let's clean.
Let's clean this real quick for you guys.
All right, we got this part.
Oh, I'm a professional now.
I'm a fucking professional now.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm a fucking professional now on this.
I feel like this- doing this increases the motion sickness.
I don't get motion sickness, but I could feel like it could.
Oh, this is- people need to learn you can't just lie on the internet anymore.
People- Lying on the internet has consequences.
If this is how I must teach, then so be it.
The outhouse base.
All right, now you tell us this new doki rule.
All right, lying has consequences.
War has changed.
I miss when you lie.
I never lie.
What are you guys talking about?
I would never do that to you guys.
What am I missing from this wall?
What the fuck am I missing from this wall?
Everything is like...
gone.
The fuck is this one percent?
Okay, there it is.
That's what it was.
Okay.
Oh my god, I'll get this post too.
I wonder if I have to clean this as well.
Do I have to clean the pathway too?
Oh my god.
Guys, please.
I need the easter egg.
I'm desperate.
We made it this far.
Okay, we got the handle.
Wait, what are we missing from the door?
Oh, is it the other side?
I guess I have to do the other side of the door too.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I definitely had to.
Oh my god.
This is so close.
Come on.
Come on, please.
I want to know what the easter egg is.
How did it go to inside the bathroom?
To like... how did it get in the house?
That's what I want to know.
Let's see.
Wait, I need to... oh, there you go.
I need to get this.
So I can actually...
clean this part.
Guys, I'm fucking professional now.
I'm a goddamn professional.
Oh, I'm such a good cleaner.
From sheer spite, I've managed to improve as a fucking janitor.
From sheer spite.
Remember when I first started cleaning at Lord Farquaad's casa?
Look at me now.
This is her now.
Jesus Christ.
In the toilet too?
Bro.
If she quits streaming, she could literally become a janitor.
Okay, we're almost done with this part.
Okay, is there... can I close this?
No.
It's like the toilet says it needs to be cleaned more, but like...
I don't see any more stains on the... oh, I shouldn't use the word stains.
Okay.
All right, we got that side of the wall.
Uh...
Like... where am I?
Oh, there.
Okay.
And the side.
Almost there.
Literally one more wall.
And then the roof.
Like, it says the toilet has like one more... where?
Here?
Okay, there we go.
And now it's time.
Where's the... where's the equipment?
It's time.
We're so close.
How do I... how?
My staircase doesn't work.
How?
Get
up!
Oh, is it the ladder?
Oh my god.
It's the ladder, isn't it?
It was the fucking ladder.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh Jesus, this isn't even glitter.
It's just fucking algae.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is... we made it.
We're gonna make it.
It's time!
Somebody!
All right, I'm gonna get the chair.
Oh,
above the door?
Oh, oh, did I miss a spot?
Oh, yeah, where?
Where have I possibly missed?
I'm getting the chair.
I'm getting it.
I'm getting the fucking chair.
Where?
How could I... oh, you mean the path?
Oh, you want me to clean the path?
Oh, okay.
Let me... let me clean the fucking path.
Oh, there was a post unclean?
What?
Where?
Where is it?
Oh, you are... oh, you're so lucky.
You're... oh, you are so lucky.
You are... you... oh.
Oh... oh...
All right, the moment of truth.
The back of it... nope.
No, you can't.
Nope.
There's nothing here.
Everything has been incredibly clean.
There's nothing else.
There's no more excuses.
Look out the window of what?
What?
There's nothing here.
What do you mean look out the window?
There's nothing else.
Fuck with me.
Don't you fuck with me.
Don't you.
Don't you fuck with me right now.
Don't you fuck with me.
I needed to clean the outhouse door and handle needs it to be cleaned first.
We're in it.
That's the secret.
That was the secret all along.
That you just wanted me to get an achievement.
That's that was it.
That was it.
You just wanted me to...
It's not even an easter egg.
How is that an easter?
Oh my god, there's that's some toes right there.
How's that an easter egg?
You're getting the chair you're You're getting you're getting the chair.
Where are you?
We're at grass.
Get over there.
Get over here right now.
I'm grabbing this chair right here.
This is
This is This is it any final words grass grass don't make
Grass don't make it harder for yourself you
Get over here grass get over you know your fate you knew what you sign up for you
Oh, oh, you don't think I didn't forget about you you got saved you got fucking saved by Evie But no one will save you grass No one is gonna save you get over here right now get here We we are here for a fucking execution and I
Get over here right now grass get over here We are all gonna watch this grass.
Don't make it harder for yourself.
I have chat history Don't make it I I can literally go back to the VODs chat history grass Don't make it harder.
You think hiding in front of all these drag goons is gonna save you
I Hope you you got your last meal tell me what was your last
Any final words you want to you want to tell you sure this is your chair and
Any final words you want to tell them before it before before it's all over Before it had a cookie.
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm ready to shoot.
This is... get your ass... type your last word right now.
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
Take your last, final words right now.
This is it.
This is your final words.
Your dragoons, your fellow dragoons might try and hide you right now.
It's been on the grass.
Yes.
All these dragoons are trying to hide you right now.
But they can't hide you from me.
I need you to type right now.
Been an honor, dragoons.
And there he goes.
There he goes.
And he's gone.
Now we learned that you cannot lie on the internet.
Now...
What we learned today is that you cannot lie on the internet no more.
You cannot lie.
Macarena, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what's even worse?
He was shadowbanned.
He can type all he wants, but nobody will see him.
That's so cruel!
He can think he's involved, but no one will ever see what he says.
No one will see his words.
He can scream, but he has no presence no more.
A fate worse than banning.
Thou shalt not lie on the internet.
Cruz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'd just like to point out, you collabed with Chill yesterday, and he has been lying on the internet for over 15 years.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yes, but it starts today.
It starts today.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How much for his- you cannot bail someone that's fucking gone!
You cannot- he's literally executed live.
You can't bail someone that's just gone, chat.
Like, he doesn't exist no more.
He doesn't even exist.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright guys, what a great way to call- end the stream.
Anyway guys, I hope you guys had a great time.
I'm gonna- I have 40 minutes to rest up before the collab.
Cruz, if you're still here, please give us a sign.
Rosen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright guys, I'm gonna head off and rest before my next collab.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed cuz you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!